Okay,
real good experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Roseanne Barr.
So bad ass.
We had to stop this podcast.
Really?
We to start early.
We couldn't,
we couldn't even wait till three.
We had to get it rocking.
She came here from a volcano.
Ladies,
gentlemen,
she lives on a volcano in the middle of
the ocean.
That's as gangster as it gets.
You and Terence Mckenna,
do you know he was.
Terence Mckenna was this crazy
psychedelic guy who lived on the big
island.
He had this giant property and the big
island where he grew all these
psychedelic plants.
Most of them were actually legal to grow
because,
uh,
you know,
the government didn't know about quite a
few of them.
You never heard of Terence Mckenna know.
So keep going.
I will,
uh,
give you a lot of stuff before you leave
that tunes into this guy.
But he was,
um,
this sort of psychedelic bard.
That's the best way to describe it.
Just a really good speaker who had a
deep understanding of psychedelics and
of,
of botany and the biology of these
plants.
And he also had some crazy theories
about human beings.
And evolution and his biggest one was
called the stoned ape theory.
Now I know that theory,
but I didn't know it was from that guy
on Mckenna and he lived out the last
part of his life on the big island.
He had this cool compound and used to
bring people up there and do Iowasca
with them.
Just those books.
That's like the third time I've heard
about that IOWASCA.
That's only the third time you've heard
it on the big island in the last little
while talking about this spreading
everywhere now.
But I think Mckenna is a big reason why
it spread all around Hawaii.
You know,
he came to Hawaii,
I forget what year,
got some property and built a house out
there on Mauna Loa.
In Kona.
Kona.
Yeah.
He had like a complete self sufficient
system up there,
like collecting rain water and they're
all crazy up there and they're the most
genius genius inventors.
They were just incredible over there.
The stuff they've done is like
incredible looking there.
So there's like,
you know,
so futuristic in their design.
It blows my mind.
Their designs are like space,
like,
well that's where the,
the observatory is to Keck observatory.
So there's a bunch of jeans.
Did you go up there?
How,
how's it haunted?
In what way?
Oh No,
no,
no.
That whole Mana,
Mana,
k a mountain,
you know,
that's a holy mountain,
Hawaiian.
But where they were born out of is that
mountain Monica.
So where they were born,
they were born.
Yeah.
Like they,
there,
they came on boats,
didn't they?
Well,
yeah,
in the more kaizens yeah.
But it's like all one big Ole mindmeld
thing,
but the native Hawaiian people who like,
I don't know how they got there,
some say they came on those boats and
uh,
but they have their,
their myths and their very connected to
that piece of ground and they are very
connected to,
you know,
Monica the mountain and uh,
they still have their same mythology and
everything,
you know.
So I love to listen to what they say
about,
um,
you know,
the island and Gmos and power and
there's some interesting thinkers.
What's one of the last free place is
really,
if you stop and think about it,
it's,
it's America,
but it's not really,
it's five hours away by plane and it's
incredible paradise as far as like
nature.
You know what?
All of the islands,
Maui,
the big island,
all of them,
they're just incredibly fascinating and
gorgeous and beautiful and,
but all that.
Everybody says all that,
you know,
that's one way of putting it I guess.
But to me it's like whoa.
It grabbed me in the naval,
grabbed you in the naval lab,
my navel and we're not let.
We're not cease to grab my navel.
That's one of your shockers,
right?
Isn't it supposed to be.
Naval is one of them.
There's something,
there's something around there that it's
like a magnet thing.
It's to,
to a certain place on earth.
I don't know.
And it's like an energy lay lance and
you know,
I,
you know what I mean?
I do.
I've written some of my best things ever
in Hawaii on vacation where I don't
usually write.
Yeah,
I can right there.
That's why I like it there because I can
really right there.
It's like your head is clear and,
and your,
you got your,
you have your,
your creative idea and you can carry it
out and finish it.
I can't never finish it,
you know,
but I can finish things there
while you are more at peace.
There are things because because
everyone sort of knows it's isolating.
You also know that you really are on a
volcano.
This beautiful natural volcano.
Well,
I went there because they got a goddess
named Pele and that's why the last place
on earth where there's like a,
you know,
a goddess so that it is active in
people's minds and act also active
inside a volcano might erupt at any
time,
which is,
you know,
um,
what happens,
you know,
it's very sufi adjust,
you know what I mean?
Because it's like somewhere there is
that which occurred that which,
uh,
is thought before it occurs.
You know what I mean?
And I really feel that they are,
that you get your,
you get your thinking,
um,
all lined up,
right?
And it's like you're connected to the
earth.
They're like me trying to my nuts out
there,
joe.
That's been the fucking mindblower.
Macadamias.
Thanks.
Yeah.
You're growing them,
right?
You have like a plantation or something
on them.
The trees are grown up.
I just pick them up,
but I try to fertilize my trees and get
it so that you can perfect the net and
this year was quite a good harvest and
uh,
these debts are like,
they're not like nobody else.
They're not like any other nuts.
I'm serious.
I believe you.
I think you were actually a part of it.
I bet you affect it just,
just in that way
do ship for it.
But it was like owned by the Dole
Pineapple,
you know about it.
They own the entire,
like an island of Lanai,
didn't they?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
At one point in time at least.
Yeah.
Them and the University of Hawaii,
they're all hooked up,
you know,
and they do do your genetic modification
studies and such,
which is very interesting to me of how,
how they do all that and then create a
pineapple that has lower acidity and
stuff like that.
I think that's interesting.
It's very interesting,
it's spooky and it's interesting at the
same time because it the implications of
genetically modifying plants or are
huge,
they're very profound and they shouldn't
just affect the people that are creating
them and putting them out there.
They're really worldwide questions and
when,
when you have people that are just
getting away with doing genetic
modifications on plants,
not really sure of the longterm
ramifications to the environment,
to bs too.
There's a host of different things that
are affected by these things.
These things.
Well,
I thought that I got.
I thought I did a pretty good checkmate
on on Monsanto,
which I called him once eight and I
thought I got them in a choke hold like
that bitch.
You're talking about that fighting Ronda
Rousey.
Nothing compared to me.
Wow.
How dare I tell you?
I put them in quite a nice headlock over
there.
What were they trying to do?
Well,
they were trying to pass a law or to get
rid of a law which took a lot of work
getting there to make law,
which was to,
you know,
that the people,
they're not want the GMO studies to
continue on the island and uh,
you know,
so it was like you got to vote yes,
but it really means now,
and I mean it was like layer after layer
of ridiculousness to protect public
health and home.
So I just started studying it and I
realized that there they,
they kept on doing that fake science
thing that they do,
but it's like,
hey,
science last more than 90 days.
Genetic studies,
proper scientific genetic studies they
have follow through and they also have a
control group and he don't,
you come to a conclusion,
you don't stop studying after 90 days.
And then like actually like pay
lobbyists to pass a law saying you only
have to do
90 days.
I mean gas,
that's Satan,
that's friggin crazy ass.
Satan.
It's money.
It's pure money.
People wanting money over humanity.
People wanting money over the
possibility of damage.
You know,
we got to be really careful with nature,
it's just there's been a million
diseases that have occurred throughout
the history of people and they come from
a variety of reasons that come from a
variety of sources that come from all
sorts of different contagions.
But we can create shit.
We could accidentally fuck up and create
something horrible and we could also,
if we haven't already,
fucking atomic weaponry,
there's the biggest fucking mistake
anybody's ever heard of and make it and
then they make it and then give every
everybody 50 or 60 of them.
Fuck,
you know,
I mean,
the truth is that horrifying truth of my
opinion.
Why I don't go to parties because I do
bump people out of certain fucking
point,
you know,
I do because it's like,
it,
it's not a popular thing to say.
It's all fucking over.
It's totally over.
It's too late to a human beings have
ruined the planet.
Fuck yeah.
See,
I'm not convinced.
I think we've definitely fucked a lot of
things up and there's definitely a lot
of hubris going on and there's a lot of
scary shit going on.
Like Fukushima,
Fukushima is bad and it started at the,
they just had a new um,
studies showing that a lot of radiation
started to reach San Francisco,
you know,
they've found a three percent increase
in some of the tune of the radiation and
tuna.
It's scary shit,
but there's also people eat fish out of
there and yeah,
I don't know who they are,
but I think
we're all poison.
Banged out over.
Everything's fucking rotten.
Poison.
Fucking it's all dead.
Is Dead.
Isn't fucking doornail and too
motherfucker.
It's not.
It's time to let that thing go really
serious.
It's time to get real and do what
fucking needs to be done.
What needs to be done?
Well,
you got you gotTa fucking get busy.
I've trying to turn it back so you've
got to keep on rolling over yet it's not
going to get better by you mean
capitalist society,
corporations,
people destroying the earth,
polluting all that shit.
Nuclear waste.
Is that what you're saying?
By Roll it back?
Oh,
everything that's lemming.
It's time for months.
Say,
tend to become of used to the human
race.
That's just my opinion.
They've got to come up with some kind
of.
They're going to do genetic studies.
Okay,
get rid of that.
Get rid of that one.
[inaudible],
come up with some kind of an implant for
people's teeth are brain that blocks
that horrendous lemming fucking impulse.
Do fucking humanity of favor and
figuring out how we're supposed to get
rid of that shit that we keep going
along with what's killing us because
we're too fucking confused to know what
the fuck is really good.
Real,
isn't it?
Just that there's just too much to be
paying attention to their own lives.
They have their own problems,
their own bills on family,
and
then each try paying attention to global
issues like genetically modified foods
and farmers suing all across the world.
The farmers in Brazil recently,
one billions of dollars from Monsanto
farm is in India.
Commit suicide on an almost daily basis.
I mean they have.
They have farmers in India that are
committing suicide left and right
because of the debt that they get into
these crazy deals.
Bullshit.
It's all been pyramid.
They can't get out of it and they can't
afford it,
and that the whole thing is just a
disaster.
It's a disaster.
It's a disaster that clearly has its
roots in money.
I mean,
it's,
it's just about heres the roads.
They're getting a payoff for the
different various ways that people can
get killed.
They're getting fucking insurance pay
off for killing people.
Uh,
you know,
and taking bets on how long it'll take
for them to die.
But on the other side,
on the other hand,
I think like the idea of genetically
modifying food in order to help people
nutritious food like golden rice and
there's been a bunch of innovation as
far as.
Absolutely.
I think that there's a lot of beauty in
the science behind it,
but I think we're going to be really,
really,
really fucking careful when you're
playing around with nature to the money
part is disgusting.
The pollution of the environment.
Disgusting.
But when you started about talking about
declining bee populations due to the
pesticides they using in their plants,
it's scary shit because if the bees go,
there's a chain reaction to this whole
thing.
We might not like the end result of it.
You got it.
Read up on that be shit.
That's.
That's a really interesting micro world
stuff,
but it's like all the stop.
The African Queens,
the invading African queens.
Have you ever gone on there?
Read them
kind of language.
That was like really?
Yeah.
No,
they were definitely afraid of African
killer bees.
They're afraid of that.
That's not why they're killing these
fucking piece.
They're killing these bees because the
pesticides are given them.
Just killed everything.
Not only that,
there.
There's a lot of patients are in
business together.
Work on both side of the street.
You think they're actively trying to
kill babies.
I think it's just a side effect.
Your solutions
kill a whole populations for a fucking
kick back.
Yeah.
You think they're actively trying to
kill whole populations of bees,
of humans,
of life mentality.
I don't think that.
I think they're just trying to profit.
I'm very positive.
See,
I told you guys bomber,
you just very strong and very
opinionated and it's all bullshit
and people better,
you know,
figure out how to make everything work
for people.
And everything could really work for all
people.
All the mechanism is in place.
It's just like the,
the,
the crazy Trans Trans and bots that seat
that are seated in,
in those positions of power.
They're not for like,
you know,
humanity.
Yeah.
I agree.
I hundred percent agree.
It does.
Uh,
the real problem is the idea of a
corporation itself where you value the
bottom line,
the numbers over the humans that work
there over the humans you affect with
your work and because you can do it like
that because you can send to place and
shoot
mrs out of the sky because you can just
sort of does choose to fuck over some
country that you never have to visit and
take,
take away a lot of their natural
resources and make them,
force them into using your product
because you have deals with politicians
and kings and monarchs there.
You know,
just because you could do that doesn't
mean that's the way you're supposed to
be living your life.
You have one life here and you could
choose to be an evil fuck.
Or you can choose to be a good person.
I always try to appeal to them to go,
you know,
you could rejoin the human race at any
point.
They all could.
They could.
They could like actually like make
stuff,
all that technology,
all that.
Everything that it took to create the
science,
the actual science of like a increasing
food for people and all and like a
desalinization of water and all these
things that are so possible.
Yeah.
Just wasn't for just a few greedy Fox
and they're and they're trons.
Absolutely.
I've always said that if you could just
take the amount of money that the United
States gave to Halliburton to rebuild
Iraq after we destroyed it and put that
money in the inner cities in America and
not have the ward not destroy anything
in the first place,
the amount of positive work that could
have been done and the same amount of
contracts could have been dealt out.
We could.
We could have all easily convinced the
money that's been spent.
It could effect on work.
It still can.
I think we have a better chance today
than ever before.
I think because today you have
inflammation,
you have information.
It's being distributed in a way that no
one can stop.
You can't stop so far,
but they stopped it.
It doesn't matter if the people that are
interested,
they can.
They are not big enough.
There's not enough of them that would
agree with that because they would turn
against each other.
It's not like there's a cabal of three
dudes that have ultimate power.
There's thousands and thousands of
people that are making decisions.
Whether or not this gets censored,
that gets censored and they're in
cahoots against each other.
That's a problem by the FBI and the CIA.
The reason why portray us got kicked
removed from office is the CIA was being
spied on by the fucking FBI.
They can't even.
That's what all NSA spying on each
other.
For sure.
Find out if he knows the shit.
I Bet Poland exactly.
We're caught up kind of runs on black
male like,
okay,
what is like?
They fucking think they're like James
Bond or something,
but it's all like they all have to be
dirty in order to blackmail the other
side.
They're all fun.
Crux,
every goddamn blast.
Fucking one of them will.
There's certainly quite a few of them
that are crooks and inside the system,
I don't know any of them,
I don't know them,
so I don't know if they're crooks are
not crooks,
but I think if you were growing up in
that system,
people imitate their atmosphere,
you get caught up in that wacky system
and that becomes your reality and you
think you're doing it,
you know,
also the side effects.
No,
I didn't see that.
I did what that insane.
Yeah.
Well isn't it?
That's uh,
that's,
that's like,
okay.
That was like fucking an unreal.
But that's what,
that's what they,
they've just gone crazy ended jackal
land.
They left a human race.
So it's people trying to do something,
you know,
they try to,
when they try to succeed,
they tried to get past this marker.
They have a marker of 10 million.
They want to get to 100.
You want to get to a billion like that.
They keep snorting coke to keep it up.
You know,
you ain't got to go farther and farther
when the stock market.
Well,
don't be telling them about adderall
because I got on adderall and it's the
best fucking thing.
Not saying there's anything wrong with
it.
I have.
My good friend is on a.
He a,
a patch that he keeps on his leg.
PROZAC.
Yeah.
It's got a PROZAC patch.
Yeah,
there's,
yeah,
exactly.
Taking the adderall but they won't
enter.
You can't get.
I asked what I'd love from us taking the
adderall,
but uh,
the dropoff at the end of the day was
too much for them.
It was really starting to drive him
crazy because he would feel great
throughout the day and be very
productive.
And then you'd have this big dropoff
well that's when you start your
drinking.
That's cocktail hour.
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with adderall,
but I am saying a lot of people that are
getting a lot of shit done or taken
adderall.
No,
she had cleaned out.
Listen,
I am sad.
I just cleaned out my closet,
which I have never done in my whole
fucking life because I can't focus to do
that,
you know?
But like I said,
fuck it.
I'm,
I might add plenty of fucking closet.
I'm have shared in there from 25 fucking
years that I was afraid to throw out.
I counted.
I had something like 1700 black plain
black tee shirts.
Wow.
How did you count those all?
I woulda gave up after the first couple
of hundred
because I was donating them.
Wow.
That's incredible.
I'm,
I'm not gonna do that again.
That's when I.
That was pre adderall behavior.
That was pre adderall.
Adderall made me see.
Oh Shit.
I had enough fucking black tee shirt.
So adderall gave you clarity on that
because my kids are trying to get me off
and why are you like math?
My fucking kids like that.
I put through Rehab.
He shared about my fucking.
I'll tell me.
He's like,
no,
it's not like I've never done math
except for,
you know,
two times I was married to Tom Arnold.
But aside from that,
you know,
I've never,
I would never get into math.
I think it's nothing like adderall.
I think they've got it down to where
it's very effective for a lot of people.
I'll tell you one thing,
it's real effective because I got the
back and forth of everything,
two way mirror thing going on all the
time.
It made me.
I used to bite my nails so bad,
you know,
like a down to nothing because my dad,
he did it too.
And uh,
and uh,
uh,
but I quit for a long time.
Then I went on adderall and um,
I started biting my nails and then I had
to keep it down to only two nails that I
could allow myself to buy it only tune,
but it perfected my fucking nail biting
because there's like no nail left at all
at all.
They're really good at it.
So good at it now.
But you give yourself two nails.
Do you have specific nails?
Yeah,
these two are my biters.
So adderall let you save your other
eight fingers essentially.
But it kind of forced me to do these two
though.
So it's got its good and bad,
but I have clean closets
and you know,
to write scripts I was able to fly a
fucking focus software.
Yeah,
that adderall stuff.
Did you know Robert Schimmel?
I did know Robert Shaw,
I'm a great guy
who's a really,
really,
really good guy.
Very,
very funny guy.
Very good guy.
He was so funny.
He had a heart condition and when he had
his heart condition,
when he was recovering from it,
he accidentally took adderall and called
his doctor up.
I guess it was somebody else's and he
mistook the bottle,
wasn't paying attention and took the
wrong medication.
It took someone else's medication and so
he calls his doctor up in a panic.
Hey,
I fucked up.
I thought it was taking my heart
medication.
I took adderall.
What am I gonna be okay,
Doctor.
Just like don't worry about it was the
dosage.
He tells me the dosage,
you're gonna be fine.
He goes,
just prepare to get a lot of shit done.
Robert said,
he goes,
I organize my notes in a way I've never
done before when over stacks of paper
and wrote them all down into categories.
Totally fucked
I guess.
I mean,
it's so good like you can,
you can write a script instead of like
getting 50 ideas on page 10 and 10
scripts and then just fucking throwing
them all in the garbage,
you know,
just the obsessive thing.
You can focus it so that it,
it's uh,
you know,
constructive.
I've heard people say that it doesn't
make you very creative that it makes you
get work done,
but it's more like busy work done or
things not creative.
Things like that.
Writing on it was not good.
This is just obviously a secondhand,
but that could be,
I don't know.
It could be.
Yeah.
I can never say because things affect
people differently anyway.
Like I know people that smoke pot and
they want to go work out and I didn't
know people that smoke pot and they
don't want to do anything,
you know,
and I don't know what that is.
They get smoked the same pod and they
have the one person has a sense of
adventure and wants to put boots on and
go to the top of a mountain and the
other person doesn't want to do a thing
ever.
They want to play video games.
It's who knows,
you know,
neural pathways.
They're all different.
We're so different.
People seek some relief.
And I,
I,
you know,
I'm sure we agree.
They,
they,
uh,
they should have the right to,
to the relief that they seek,
uh,
you know,
everybody,
they should just legalize pot and like
then I think all the troubles
would end pot and ham.
I really agree with you 100 percent.
I think that especially people started
eating it,
they started eating,
getting that self objective,
self analytical experience,
really intense experiences.
People will be a lot less prone to
continue a lot of their shitty behavior
that I does.
Mckenna's theory of evolution in the
first theory.
Yeah.
It was all about psilocybin mushrooms
and the rain forests of Africa,
how the rain forest has had receded into
grasslands and all this is proved by
climatological studies,
core samples and stuff like that.
The time has been debated,
but essentially what happened was the
rainforest receded monkeys came down
from the trees and started experimenting
with different food sources and one of
them was the mushrooms growing on
calpads.
Oh yeah.
I've heard that you started eating
psilocybin mushrooms and started having
these intense ideas.
I mean,
it only makes sense if we get intense
ideas from them and we're having
advanced brain and a monkey gets intense
and experiences from.
They obviously have intelligent brains
mean.
We've seen chimps do a lot of really
crazy creative things.
We know that the act impacts.
We only hunt in packs were talking about
like lower hominids getting a dose of
psilocybin mushrooms on a daily basis.
Of course it's going to have a crazy
effect on their evolution.
Of course it's.
That's a,
that's a big factor.
It's a big factor in,
in terms of thinking,
you know,
I and I completely agree with you that
and Hampton,
all these different things.
If they were made available,
I think we are lacking in self analysis
and we're lacking as a society and our
feeling of being responsible for the
actions of the group and those are two
things that you feel.
It's so arrogant too because it's like
we just like ignore what everything
means to other people.
We,
we don't want to know what anything
means to other people.
We don't care as long as we can make
money,
like if you're going to go to the rain
forest and chopped down these people,
sacred trees and villages and force them
to work in factories instead,
if they'll.
If they're willing to do it,
then we're going to get them to do it
because we want those trees.
When we want that oil and whatever the
fuck else is there that we can make
medicine out of mean what they're doing
is just stealing resources and we're
letting them.
We're letting them say,
oh,
this stuff,
yeah,
they don't live here.
This is so what they've been in.
These people have been there for
thousands of years and say anybody who
has eminent domain,
tribal rights,
that's what they're really after.
It's crazy.
They're trying to get rid of that
separate.
All people from like from nature.
You can't stop people from having the
ability to live a natural life just
because you have guns just because you
have tanks that stealing and if we're
going to just let people steal shit.
If these people were there in the middle
of the Amazon,
that's their fucking home.
That's their home.
You have to be able to take into
context.
Their culture is culture of hunting and
gathering.
They're living in these,
these cultures,
the same way they've been living in some
places like in the Congo and the in the,
in the Amazon thousands of years it had
been untouched.
You can't do anything about that.
You got to leave that alone.
You know you have to because just as far
as like for the sake of our
understanding of ourselves,
having like that with these ancient,
ancient untouched cultures is so
important.
It's so fascinating.
We can learn so much about the origins
of certain behaviors,
about group thinking when you were in
small tribes that counter each other
about how they dealt with injuries and
medicine.
I mean these are fascinating,
fascinating discoveries to be had and
instead people just want money.
They just want to be able to chop the
trees down.
Fuck these weird people,
take their shit and throw them in a
cage.
You know,
capitalism is like that.
That's how it works.
Unless you know,
unless,
unless human beings would brains,
you know,
get it under control as a tool of people
and not its master,
it'll continue to go that way because it
requires that it requires gluttonous
quarterly growth and there's nothing
left but invest in people dying fast.
Yeah.
They don't want to maintain,
they want growth,
which is ridiculous.
Like at a certain point in time,
have everybody kept growing.
The world would be full.
Like there's,
there's no room,
there's no room for everybody to keep
growing a business in that regard.
Like that being your primary goal.
Not to be profitable,
not to make money.
Well,
I think these guys are stupid.
Let me tell you why,
because it makes no sense to me because,
okay,
I accept that they're greedy fucking
pigs and um,
I just think why can't they make that
work for them and everyone else,
why can't they be a greedy fucking pig?
Because they're going to get like 10
times the fucking pay off.
They will get even richer if they'll
just listen to me make all the bats
because like Wall Street and all that
shit.
That's just going to the casino,
make all the bets about how fast you can
turn a place,
a green and sustainable,
and how fast could that happen.
A village,
how fast could that happen and you know,
they they could like use the same
fucking ridiculous infrastructure that
already exists to like make things
better for everybody and could get the
food to the hungry people because
there's really.
That's all it is,
is the roads that get the food to the
hungry people.
That's 90 percent of everybody who's
dying is dying because of waste and
stupidity.
Now,
if they fixed that,
they're going to get 10 times fucking
richer,
but they're not greedy fucking pigs
enough.
That's the problem.
All avenues as being a way to make
money.
Even avenues that hurt people,
as long as they profit,
that's the real problem.
They're mad,
they're lacking in humanity and that's
why when you talk about pot being what
could fix everything or psychedelics
being what could fix things,
that's the only thing that's going to
bring humanity to a giant group.
Think that thinks that it's okay to be
completely diffused of responsibilities
because you're a part of some gigantic
machine that apparently no one can
control now,
so if you're a giant machine like
Monsanto,
this has been fucking over farmers for
100,000
years or however long they've been
around for to that
to stop that whole thing.
They're going to have to get the whole
team high on mushrooms now,
but it worked.
Did it?
Didn't you hear this that Monsanto said
they were going to.
Now they're going into pot.
Did you not hear that?
They're fucking good.
They're changing their thing and and
they have another name for it.
Center just or some shit.
You have another name for pot?
Our new company.
Yeah.
They're going to own the patent on
pockets where it gets really creepy.
They tried to own patent on pigs.
They tried to own pigs because pigs.
I was totally involved in that argument.
I was wondering because I was like,
can you can,
can we create a kosher pig that.
That's an actual thing.
There was an actual studies about that
idea of patenting and then owning a life
form is fucking ridiculous.
Kosher pig though.
I think it would be really cute.
It would be.
You'd have to.
Was Nicer,
nicer stuff would look better.
It wouldn't be clothing.
What would it be?
The genetically altered?
What would be the other options?
You want to keep it like they'd make a
pig into a chow or something.
I guess like they made a fish out of a
tomato,
you know that,
right?
I mean a tomato out of a fish.
They put fish genes in the tomato to
make it shiny in the grocery store.
Yeah.
No,
they're doing a lot of weird shit like
that.
They've always been doing that.
That's what I was saying about my farm,
that Dole pineapple that my farm is
where they did a lot of shit like that
and here it is.
Like I don't know how many generations
later,
but my fucking nuts are like,
they're like walnuts.
I'm telling you.
You think it's because of the
genetically modified dirt or something,
whatever these fucking things.
Three of them is a meal really?
Is the perfect protein.
How did you get involved in macadamia
nuts?
How this whole thing gets started?
God,
well,
I tried to look for a school to put for
my kid because my kid,
he's 18 now,
but he was little and he needed to go to
a school that had focused because I
don't have any focus so I wasn't able to
teach him how to focus or else he was
born that way or some shit.
But uh,
I can't tell so I put them in that
school.
So then I went out,
I went over and I found this school,
so I went over there and I bought this
farm site unseen.
Really moved into it.
What island?
A big island.
So there was a really good school.
I knew it was elvis favorite island.
I went there.
And you know that that's where Elvis
was.
That's where Elvis?
Yes.
That's the spot though.
If you've never been to the observatory
up there.
No.
They said don't go up there.
No,
because it could erupt at any fucking
time.
Really?
Yeah.
That an active,
active Montello is active,
right?
Monica Monica is active.
Yeah.
I guess I think they give you a little
bit of warning before it blows,
but a return and a I just returned in
the corner in my car just as it happened
when it hit,
I know it.
I tweeted a picture today of a bridge
falling apart of a,
a road actually falling apart.
Just some cracks in the road.
A landslide.
This gigantic.
That's one thing you do have to think
about.
If you live in Hawaii,
do you have to think about the fact that
you're living on a volcano?
Do you know?
I'm not making this up.
You won't fucking believe this is the
kind of shit the atms to me and I'm not
making it up.
I believe you.
I was sitting at my desk here where I
live,
you know,
in the,
in the marina
and uh,
I just hit send on something incendiary
thing that I'd worked on all day.
Fucking incendiary tweet that had z.
was that perfect zero.
You know what I mean?
Right.
When you get to the numbers,
140 characters,
it's 1:30
fucking seven shit.
Now I have to alter the top of it,
like it for obsessive people,
but I just hit sand and right then I
felt an earthquake right on my fucking
desk and I went on line and it was,
it had hit Marina del Rey right where I
was sitting where I sit and I'm like,
don't fucking go crazy because I was
alone.
I'm like,
don't fucking free cow.
Run into the street screaming,
knocking on their neighbors.
Don't fucking do that.
Stay in here.
Get some emotional control.
You've just lived through a fucking,
you know,
whatever it's called.
The earth moving.
Yeah.
Earthquake.
So I calm myself down.
So I go back to Hawaii the first night
there.
There's another one.
I almost lost my shit.
It was just beginning finding.
Yeah.
It's so terrifying.
You think of all these people like you
know,
they're,
they're just there and here comes a
tidal wave and here comes a tsunami.
I mean how,
how vulnerable we are to all of these
elements and why and stuff and people
don't think about it.
It's terrifying.
Shit.
You can have a fucking nervous breakdown
over that when you definitely can.
I mean,
there's always going to be the problem
that human beings die.
They were very finite and whether or not
we get hit with an earthquake or a
tsunami or hurricane,
we're going to die anyway.
I know.
That's really the terrifying part.
Yeah.
That's the one.
That's the big one.
And then you're sitting there all the
time wondering how you're going to die,
you know,
like,
are you upset?
Are you scared of that at all?
Do you think of that?
No,
not that much.
No.
The only,
what I think about the big worry for me
would be leaving behind my kids.
Yeah.
That would be the big worry,
you know,
making them sad.
But uh,
we're going to die.
I mean,
I don't want to.
Right now I'm enjoying life.
I'm pretty sure it's inevitable
unless something crazy comes along
technologically over the next hundred
years when that'd be cool.
They say that it's there.
I don't know if it would be cool because
I don't know what's next.
I'm not convinced that this is the,
a one stop shop.
Like we land in life and this is it,
and this is,
this is where our soul is,
where energy is.
This is the ultimate stop of our
existence.
Convinced why do you think you'd go
after this?
I don't know,
but just the fact that this exists.
Just the fact that this life that we
live in where we can communicate with
our mouth,
where we can see with our eyes where we
walk around and drive around flying
planes.
This life is so fucking insane and so
crazy and bizarre and fantastic.
Just this.
The idea that this existence exists
where we shut off every night for eight
hours and completely vanished from the
reality that we live in,
and then we do it willingly and then
we'd come back in the morning and we
start all over again.
That alone is fucking fantastic and
bizarre and strange.
I'm not convinced that when we die,
this ends.
I'm not convinced.
I'm not convinced that anybody dies.
I'm not convinced that this whole thing
is in just one series of wake ups and
goes and sleeps and wakes up and go and
while your conscious and while you're
alive,
I'm not convinced that you're in the
same timeline that you were on before.
I think we're Sam's.
We could be.
I mean that's what a lot of people far
smarter than me are arguing.
You could almost prove that we are part
of some sort of a crazy gigantic
computer simulation,
but that might be what the universe is
in the first place.
The whole thing might be.
I mean that might be with nature as we
try to look at nature as being something
that's,
you know,
this is rock and this is dirt and these
are one.
Yeah,
shorter until you break it down to
molecules,
the tear breakup time summit,
atomic particles that exist everywhere.
Patterns.
When you break it down to like a genetic
fibonacci sequence and things along
those lines like that.
You don't need any bigger mystery than
this now as well.
I know today,
Charlie Helen,
great comic.
He died.
He left the earth.
I was just talking about him the other
day with Jamie Masada,
even aside from the laugh factory,
was telling me how sick you have no
idea.
Yeah,
he just went last night and boy,
he was like a comic and a great person.
Very,
very good person.
I've known that guy for a long time.
It was always a very,
very nice guy.
Yeah,
he was.
He was.
He's a good comic.
Funny Dude.
Native American to lug jokes about white
people steal his land.
He said.
He Goes,
God damn,
I'm so glad you called because he's of
here.
Diane and all.
I'm only here from a b list convicts.
That's hilarious.
Who's hyper you stopped in for guests at
that he got.
He goes,
not because he said Jane and David and
everybody had already called them,
but he was still writing jokes,
you know?
Right in the very
end of it.
Right enough.
I can joke.
Yeah.
That was the way that guy was.
He was fun guy.
Very,
very nice guy.
Fun Guy to be around.
Well,
look at this again.
Uh,
what's happening with that?
You know,
the native,
the first nations people that otherwise
people can't hear you.
I'm sorry for drag it to you.
You could drag it back to take a look at
like first nations stuff in the United
States and how that's just.
It's very fascinating to be come more
informed on that subject.
Yes.
Essentially genocide.
I mean that's essentially what happened
to the native Americans.
Their culture was wiped out.
There were stuck into these small camps
and fenced in and given these areas and
those areas eventually became casinos in
some spots.
I mean,
it's the weirdest absorption of a
concert.
Right?
They don't get any of that money.
There's only a couple tribes that got
any of that money.
I believe it.
Remember why that Jack Abramoff walked
off with about $30 million from it at
the bureau of Indian affairs.
No,
I didn't know about this.
Who is that guy?
He's one of those banks,
jurors that got caught and I think he
got four years yet still all that.
The bureau of Indian affairs money,
$30 million of those casinos are
fucking.
The whole situation is crazy because
it's not like it's all native Americans
that own and operate those places.
Other people are involved too that are
profiting off of these casinos that are
in places where it's supposed to be
illegal.
But in native American ones,
because
they had me meet some of their,
uh,
native council or something.
Yeah.
You got in trouble.
Yeah,
because I go.
I know you're,
you're Italian,
you're Jewish.
I know you're,
I know you're Jewish.
I'm,
I could tell that they were Italians and
Jews.
They weren't frigging native Americans.
Native American.
Did he have to be,
do you have to be 100 percent 50 50 by
the Roseanne Barr scale scale to scale
of each tribe makes their own thing.
It's mostly 50.
Mostly 50 or it could be your
grandparents to 25,
but it has to be pretty 50 slash 50 like
in Hawaii.
One thing I think so cool is that they
do have a lot of affordable housing for
the first nations people there.
You know,
the Hawaiian people and they get,
they're like guarantee of school and
like they got,
you know,
Hawaii,
the big island,
Hawaii has a fantastic socialist state
and you know,
um,
I think that it's just going to make the
big turnaround real quick because
China's just said no gmos,
so we kicked their ass out.
So now I think we're going to like have
a boom,
but we do need some of that technology
because I think we want to grow organic
seeds with help.
We don't want to reinvent the organic
seed.
We want to grow organics with
technology.
So it's an incredible new,
odd time of,
you know,
mixing the best everything.
So what you're talking about is not
genetically modifying the foods but
using technology to more efficiently
till the soil more officially irrigate
the crops more efficiently,
put nutrients into the ground,
things along those lines,
right?
Yeah.
That's stuff that works well.
Not only that,
the stuff that we know the cause and
effect of,
we know it's healthy.
We know it's a part of the ecosystem.
We know that there's just a rich
biodiversity when it comes to any place
where something's growing.
There's bugs involved in rodents,
evolved and BS.
There's a lot of things involved.
It's not just the plant itself.
When you alter the plant,
the real issue seems to be that you
alter a lot of other shit too.
And then of course,
I don't know how much of this is true or
not,
but the idea of cross pollenization and
people being sued because they have
genetically modified foods growing in
their,
in their farms because of inadvertent
cross pollinization.
I mean honestly,
there's very few people who have only
organic's really?
Yeah.
Most farmers there have a mix,
but I think now it's been tilted to
where it's going to become more and
more,
uh,
you know,
moving towards a 100 percent organic,
no pesticides and this and that and the
other.
But in order to do that,
you've got to reverse a lot of things.
Like you can't let them be spraying
overhead anymore.
They can't be spraying aluminum and
Barium all day if you're going to grow.
Do you,
are you seeing you saying chem trails,
the aluminum barium shit.
You know,
I did a whole Saifai special on the
Scifi channel,
a whole episode dedicated to chem trails
and the more attention to it,
the more I think that people are very
confused as to what's going on.
The government,
I guarantee without a doubt has sprayed
things on people.
They've proven it.
They did it.
I believe it was Detroit.
There was a recent thing they talked
about doing it in the 19 fifties.
They did tests to see what would happen
if a,
the Communists said came over here and
did some sort of a nuclear attack on the
population or poisonous gas attack.
I,
if they.
They sprayed particles so they could
track them.
They don't know what the fuck that's
going to do to people.
They've done things where they've done
done experiments on the.
Whether they've done.
They figured out how to cloud seeding by
just doing it.
I mean,
they knew the science behind it,
but it's not like they had a vote on the
entire world and ask people,
Hey,
can we see clouds or what do you,
what do you guys think?
You know,
no,
fuck it.
They just did it.
The government has done things along
those lines for a long time.
People think that they bring on
earthquakes too and
yeah,
we talked about that as well and aside
fi show,
but here's the problem.
There is science behind those trails.
There's a.
You can track when it's gonna happen and
when it's not going to happen and it's
all based on the humidity in the
atmosphere.
That's what it's all based on.
When you have a jet engine and it burns
jet fuel and it's going through the
atmosphere,
it's creating moisture and in conditions
where it's almost cloud like,
like very hazy when a jet engine pass
through this change of atmosphere and
adding moisture creates a cloud.
So when you see those patterns and
people go,
oh,
they're spraying us.
No,
they're actually creating a cloud with
the natural effect of a jet engine
passing through a certain amount of
humidity.
That's why you see them in some days,
but other days you don't see.
No.
It's just a natural side effect of jet
travel.
Not only that,
they've known about it since the 19
forties.
In the 19 forties,
there was a paper written by the army
where they were asking what?
What about these things that you see
behind planes?
They called them consistent condensation
trails,
persistent rather persistent
condensation trails.
They didn't call him contrary.
I was back then,
so they were trying to figure out what
those things are and they realized that
this is just what happens if you get an
engine the past through the environment,
burn fuel and create moisture that in
certain conditions it creates clouds.
See when people start talking about
aluminum and Barium and all that
different Shit,
look,
there's aluminum in everything.
Not only that,
the ground is filled with fucking
aluminum and a lot of these guys that
are doing these tests locally found
aluminum in the water.
When you look at their test,
it actually says sludge,
like what in the world are they
spraying?
This is a conversation I had with the
guy on the air.
It says sludge sludges,
dirt,
dirt and water,
and he's saying,
look,
there's all this aluminum in this water,
and I'm like,
that's not water.
That's water with dirt.
So what you're telling me is you did a
scientific test that showed that dirt
tested positive for being dirt because
that's what it is.
Dirt has seven,
10 percent aluminum in it,
sometimes less,
sometimes more.
Aluminum is one of the most common
things you can find in dirt.
So when someone does a test and says,
look,
this aluminum is proof,
they're spraying this guy's no fucking
aluminum is a part of nature.
It's everywhere.
It's in the ground or not.
If they were spraying it,
why would they be spraying?
Hey,
what would it look like?
Well,
here's what it wouldn't look like.
Clouds aluminum's heavy.
If you spray it,
it's much heavier than moisture.
Will you seen in those things in the
clouds?
Well,
there's real chem trails.
You know,
one of the real chemistry.
Let's hold on a second.
They're burning fucking millions of
gallons of fuel in the atmosphere that's
real.
Forget about this craziness of them
spraying shit.
Honest.
It's going to alter our personalities.
They're burning fuel in the sky and we
all take part of this.
You did to get here from Hawaii I did to
get here from Vegas this past weekend.
We're all a part of it,
but what it is for sure is not good.
You're burning fucking fuel in the sky.
That's the real camp trail where you're
seeing those cloud things.
They're not spraying chemicals at a
cloud.
It's not some gigantic conspiracy that
the whole world is in the dark about and
all these politicians are in on and
knowledge.
Do you know how many fucking people
would have to be quiet everyday on a
daily basis?
If they really were spraying aluminum on
people and if they were spraying
aluminum on people,
it wouldn't look like clouds.
Those are.
They look like clouds because they are
clouds.
I've asked scientists,
they said if you had aluminum dust,
he sprayed.
It wouldn't look anything like those
clouds.
Even Monsanto says that they are are
they need to have a radio engineering
they need.
They need a reflection because of what's
in the soil.
A reflection.
Yeah.
They need like to create a mirror.
What do you mean?
Oh,
that's what it is.
It's a mirror.
Oh,
you.
You're talking about spraying the sky
that Monsanto said that?
No,
they didn't.
They did.
No,
it's a mirror.
It's a mirror effect.
People say this.
I said,
I know.
I don't know.
Those people are fucking.
They can project the movie that they
planned on fucking putting us all
through the war.
You're on an island.
Too long going crazy.
He goes nuts.
That was crazy.
Nuts and got your fucking mind warped.
I know people say that,
but people also say that all the leaders
of the free world or actually reptiles,
they also say that.
Go that far.
I'm glad.
I'm glad you have a fucking.
Aliens are common to those with the
planet and a felon and all that.
Whatever it's called.
I don't go there neither.
It's Nibiru is the planet and it's the
Annunaki.
No,
no,
no.
I don't know.
They do know
that there's something out way,
way out far past Jupiter and past Pluto
and they think that a bigger actually in
Jupiter,
they think it might be actually four
times the size of Jupiter at least,
so they think it might be a brown star,
a star that's died out and they think
that this source system where might
actually be a binary source system.
So it's a brown dwarf star and I'm
apparently there's as many binary star
systems as there are,
um,
with,
with a single star.
There's a lot of them.
It's like super common.
And if that's the case,
that makes sense for a lot of things
including pluto because Pluto's a small,
it's not really a planet,
like that's why they stopped having it
be a plant anymore.
They realize it's a part of the Kuyper
belt was this huge belt of,
of objects way out at the edge of the
solar system.
But that there's a thing called the
galactic shelf.
This is big dropoff afterwards,
which would indicate there's something
absolutely massive just outside of it.
This is all butchered science,
but I'm not a scientist obviously,
but so they think if there is a planet
out there as something out there that
these people you know or trying to
describe that more likely,
it's like a brown dwarf star,
but it's no people on it.
It's just a giant mass of something.
I think there might be people,
well,
there couldn't be somewhere.
If there is us,
if there's us,
there could be somewhere.
The real problem with the alien thing is
that everyone you talked to that says
they've met aliens or they know aliens
real.
They're almost all fucked up.
Almost.
Almost 100 percent.
So hard.
Weird.
It's like,
I don't believe I don't not believe in
aliens.
I absolutely believe that aliens could
be real.
Just like I believe in spiders,
spiders,
spiders are fucking crazy.
You ever met an alien though?
No,
I don't believe so.
I mean I might've.
I think if you're smart enough to come
here and be an alien,
you're smart enough to also take a
human.
I mean we have fucking camouflage that
we put on jets where you can't see them
on radar.
You know,
we have hunters that were clothes that
looked like trees.
They stand in the.
No one even sees them.
Look,
it's real obvious.
They could pretend to be a person if
you're so smart,
you could get here from the planet.
Fuck yourself a billion,
trillion light years away.
Why can't tend to be made on what if
they're less than less than than me.
They're called
now they are bought and they are created
and programmed and set upon innocent
people from our government and this
government from the the government of
the beast,
the government of the beast,
so the money behind the whole wholesale.
The other problem with that is they're
not smart enough to make that,
so you'd have to get people smart enough
to make that.
And the consensus science right now is
not capable.
A Bot like that,
the consensus science right now,
it's not a fake person.
That's bullshit.
No sex dolls.
They're close,
but it's not going to trick me.
Well,
that's just what they're showing you,
but they're 50 years ahead of that shit.
They.
The problem with that kind of thinking
is the people that are in control,
so they have the whole Republican think
sewed up forever,
the people that are in control or not
smart enough to create all this stuff.
This stuff has to be created by
scientists,
the scientists.
It's all documented stuff like
everything that's being done.
All the stuff that's being done today is
all based on the technology that's been
created by geniuses over the past
hundred years from Tesla,
Edison on down the line,
all these different people have added
their campaign contributions and is a
very clear line between how these things
get created,
so when you have all this fantastic
stuff like giant televisions and
satellite Internet and all this,
there's a direct line that shows how all
this stuff came about,
but yet they can't sell gay,
clean water or food to the hungry.
Not that they can't,
it's just that they haven't figured out
a way to make it so profitable that it's
more profitable than than destroying the
environment and stealing people's
resources and leaving behind horrible
pollution because that's profitable.
That's the way they're doing it.
The real problem is that the
corporations are allowed to act like
this,
that individuals become a part of the
corporations.
And then what is it?
No,
I really want to say this is how you're
going to be at,
you know,
jump in there.
But uh,
you know,
uh,
oh.
I think I lost the thought.
No,
I did.
I lost the fuck fucking what you were
saying was that what I was saying that
you reacted to was that they need to
figure out how to still remain human and
that the problem is when you have a
corporation,
you have this big giant group of people
that's allowed to act in and make money
without any consideration mentioned.
Didn't say
yeah,
because it's government.
The government that they hate and they
all talk about,
oh,
well we out have a big government and
they're all on government money.
While they're saying that the replay.
Oh,
all of them.
Everybody who hates the big government
is sucking on the t to big government
and that's their job.
They're getting paid to go out there and
say,
we hate big government.
We need to keep government in check.
But government is the thing that keeps
that shit in Czech government is the
only power that people have.
Government is the way,
and there's no,
there's no loss and it has to be a bunch
of corrupt fuck fucking people that are
for sale and whores and shit.
There's that.
Eat the law.
It could actually be people who
understood what being a true
representative of the American people
means.
I think we should start a,
um,
America.
Here's my solution because I like to
think of solutions rather than just yap
about problems like the left and the
right because they're fucking idiots who
can invent anything.
But,
um,
you know,
I,
I think we could fix everything,
uh,
in a real big fat fucking hurry.
We could fix the economic system if we
want it to.
Well,
we just put fucking regulations on it.
All the things that existed,
you know,
before Reagan took them away and sold
down the fucking river,
just put them back.
Did you ever watch that documentary
inside job?
Yes.
Fantastic.
Because wasn't it great?
Yeah.
Terrifying.
Terrifying and fantastic.
And the guy who got on coke,
they're the fucking guys in the wolf of
Wall Street.
Yeah,
exactly.
And the guy who created actually give
him some credit right now I'm Charles h
dot Ferguson.
And he's,
he's awesome.
It was a really fantastic job.
He did.
It was just a brilliant and insightful
view on how these problems occur.
Who Profits,
how these people that start out as
people who are the educators who are
recommending the economic,
uh,
professors that are recommending certain
standards and those standards get passed
and these guys wind up getting giant
jobs with the banks that profited from
them changing the regulations.
It's fucking madness.
It's just shelving.
It's on everybody's face.
Yeah.
Well they get off on that now for the,
they,
you know,
they used to like hide net with their
secret organizations.
But then they made a big change once
they started on that cocaine,
then they like to put it in people's
face and they kept coming with it and
it's like not just put in their face but
bend over and spread their ass cheeks
and rub it right on your nose.
A vacation house.
They are,
they are just like,
sure they can get away with anything and
they have been allowed to get away with
anything.
Not Wireless fucking ever been arrested.
I think that's what's going to change
and I think it's going to change because
of the Internet because this information
was all hidden before we use this same
type of behavior.
It's not new.
It's not that it just erupted in 2000,
whatever.
It's been around forever.
You know?
We have the direct line that we learned
about the kind of regulations that
Reagan had stopped and what,
what happened from then to the Bush
administration.
We know all that stuff now,
but they just moved while it was all
going on a private
pockets,
so that's the short of it.
They made laws that made it possible for
them to do that,
but this is so incredible about it is
that it seems that,
and this is why I ran for president
because it was like when are they going
to put a a,
a,
an American person,
like a working American person in a seat
at those tables where money is
apportioned.
Well,
that ever happened,
you mean a person that represents the
average person,
the average,
the of the public of John and Joan q
public.
So I think we should start a,
I think that should be the name of our
corporation of Americans ink and that we
should apply for a privatized contracts
like everybody else is doing.
So America,
ANC being,
you know,
there's a friend of mine that's starting
a business,
a more of an avenue rather for,
for people to fund politicians the way
corporations have been funny politicians
and to encourage politicians that are
responsible and ethical and that you
could profit from that just as much as
you could profit from having worked for
some evil corporation.
And that if you got like sort of almost
like a kickstarter type thing to,
uh,
to represent like strong ethical
position.
But anytime you put money into it's
going to be wrong and suck ass.
But if it's all transparent,
the idea being,
if they're not representing a
corporation that's going to profit
instead,
they're representing people that want
more activity and ethics.
See the money,
there's profit.
You see what I'm saying?
But you see what I'm saying though,
like people would be willing to
contribute and then someone else will
control your system though.
But I don't think it would be their
system anymore.
It'll be our system if it was done
correctly.
What I'm saying is that our system would
be different than the system right now
because there wouldn't be a need for
profit.
So the need for profit exists now where
you,
you get the politicians take the money
from the corporations,
the corporations give them money because
they want profit.
This would be people giving them money
because they want ethics and morality
and a healthy society.
So I think the,
so much money comes from taxpayers as it
is to have that be an option instead to
have it.
People donate,
people that really care about it,
donate a certain amount.
If everybody donates a little,
it would be a staggering amount of money
out of 300 million people,
right?
I,
yes.
And See,
I've gone to therapy,
um,
you know,
there,
there is the public common wealth and
uh,
you know,
for people who do pay taxes and they
should get something back for the taxes
they pay,
that's the whole point.
Right?
And it should be in the form of
hospitals,
schools,
uh,
clinics,
free legal advice.
I mean,
that's what you pay your fucking taxes
for healthcare.
That's why I get paid for roads and
other things too.
You certainly don't pay your taxes to
subsidize somebody whose statement from
you
100 percent.
I agree.
I not only that,
I would take it a step further and say
community centers should be mandatory in
almost community where kids can go with
they're protected,
where they can learn things,
where they can learn sports and skills
and games and places where they can,
you know,
we can educate in inside of communities.
I think that will be just like a gas
station should be a normal part of every
sort of,
uh,
any sort of city or town.
And it should be funded,
should be funded by the government
because it's there to improve kids.
And did there to improve people,
but education free as fuck across the
board,
straight through the university all the
way to the end.
We should pay for that.
We should make it,
we should make it tough to get into.
You have to work hard.
But it's fucking free.
Education.
College education was free in California
before.
And that's a first thing.
Reagan got rid,
of course.
Yeah.
He was governor.
I'm not shocked and that should be free.
Um,
college mean we can't encourage
laziness,
but we can certainly support people that
want to learn and make it so that it's
less of a thing.
I mean,
one of the reasons why good doctors get
so God damn greedy is because they got a
fucking huge bill behind them from La,
from medical school.
So many people go into by the time
they're into office,
they have these giant fucking.
All these kids that are
getting out now,
they're in a big old financial hole.
You know,
they're in a whole.
And what it means is,
I mean this is just part of the scam and
all that was like,
as their parents signed,
you know,
where their house is,
houses away for the education,
then they come and take the house.
Hello.
It's just a big frigging Ponzi scam.
It's the shell game times a million.
Well,
it's even more of the shell game when
it's obvious that when you find out that
the banks actually banked on people
faulting on their loans.
Yeah.
Defaulting people falling apart and
being held their homes repossessed.
They actually banked on that,
profited off of it.
That really pissed me off because it was
like,
you know,
then what that means is like,
what that means in terms of cost,
real cost,
not bullshit paper cost,
but real customer community.
That means a lot more little kids are
getting going to get beaten to death.
And it means a lot more little kids are
going to get trafficked.
And you know,
uh,
I do think the poverty,
just putting that on people.
So you can have a,
you know,
gambier fourth mistress and another,
uh,
you know,
it.
Endangered Species.
Kate.
Yeah.
Said she saved the best content in the
history of the Internet.
Give you a fourth mistress it endangered
species.
K,
what kind of Cape would you make?
Like,
like a human skulls to stitched all
together as a class when you walk in
virgin blood vials dangling around your
neck with clocks.
Tramp.
That's a real baller though.
If he's got four mistresses,
guys responded.
But until you see,
um,
like my boyfriend always says whenever
we see a,
you know,
when we're here in California originally
a rich old fucker and is,
you know,
strip or wife.
And Johnny always says,
that is
proof that our currency is sound.
That's funny.
Proof that our currency is sound.
That was actually very funny,
but you know,
I mean,
when you make everything for sale,
you know,
pretty soon.
Yeah.
Money doesn't mean anything.
That's why I think they're such fucking
geniuses.
Here's how fucking stupid they are.
But they think they're smart.
The Financial Wizards,
the smart guy,
the money guy,
the money guys.
Yeah.
They're so fucking stupid.
They,
they make everything at a certain point
it's going to hit a wall and end and
they put that right in there too.
It can't go on.
It's not sustainable.
It's going to crash and you're going to
fucking get caught.
But I think that's what they like
because they're so sociopath's.
They liked the fucking people over parts
so much.
You know,
they just keep denying that there's
going to be a reckoning,
but of course there is,
and that's already happening.
I fucking reckoning right now on Wall
Street and everybody knows it,
but nobody talks about it.
Well,
I think that's just what people do.
Norton or ordinarily without logic and
without,
without enlightenment.
That's what we do as far as what we do
as far as the pollution of the
environment as far as global warming.
You're right,
you're right.
People would not do that.
You're right,
because they will factor in the true
cost.
Not the.
Not the one in the books that you have
to cook.
Oh,
I'm 100 percent agreement with you,
but I think that the consequences of
their actions or just something that
like,
Eh,
I'll deal with that eventually.
Yeah.
They don't think they're like
engineering this,
this idea of infinite growth.
Hit the wall.
Yeah.
And,
and they fuck over like all the old
people and everything.
They fuck over every and then right
away,
what's the first thing they do?
They start working on the other side of
the street.
They go to Rehab,
right.
And they,
then they come out,
you know,
I've been sober for 14 days and then you
have,
I have
to like say Goddamn fucking is such a
hypocritical.
And then they go and they,
they work to try to stop corruption.
That's my favorite.
Expose corruption and write books on
this is.
It's all like so crazy.
I think though that the.
See what I'm saying is that I think
people do shit when they think that.
It's like why do people smoke
cigarettes?
They know the consequences or cancer.
They know they're going to get it.
But then eventually,
but the smoke right now is better for me
than not having a smoke.
So I want to write down the
consequences.
Fuck it.
I'll deal with them later.
And I think that's a lot of times when
people are saying when they're,
when they're creating these sort of laws
that allow them to.
The concept of infinite growth doesn't
make any sense.
It doesn't work on paper.
There's only a certain amount of
resources,
a certain amount of space on earth.
Like if you just keep counting numbers,
you're going to run out of space.
I think they're going like,
this is shit is over now.
As much
as I can grab that advanced,
I think what people are doing is just
doing what people have always done.
Acting without that much concern for the
consequences because they don't have to
deal with the consequences right now.
It's like when,
when you get up in the morning and you
know,
and you look at,
this is a cake from last night that
looks so delicious and it's right next
to like all your fresh vegetables that
you were thinking about making a hemp
protein shake with.
I,
I get a lot of times to go for that
cake.
You know why?
Because fuck it.
It's right there.
You know,
I know it's bad for you.
I know it's sugar.
I know I'm going to feel like shit
later,
but right now I'm going to feel good to
feel good when I eat that red velvet,
own yummy,
yummy,
yummy.
And I think that's what these folks are
doing that we're not gonna do that.
If your intent is to,
you know,
lose two pounds by three days from now,
you're going to fuck.
You know,
you need adderall.
But I don't really go for the cake.
I'm pretty healthy.
But what I'm saying is it's an instinct
if,
well it's a lower instincts based on the
Peter Principle and all that shit and
the peanut peanut.
What's that one penis principles.
That one,
I can't think of.
Whatever can go wrong will go wrong.
Whatever.
Is that one?
I can't remember.
Um,
what is it called?
You know what I mean?
Yes.
Maybe it's broken my brain.
I normally have that right there.
It could with a slight alternative.
Murphy's law,
Monsanto could fix murphy's law I was
using.
It can be confusing it with Moore's law.
Um,
I wonder,
Monsanto could come up with a chip,
a chip or wherever,
but you know what they would do with
that chip?
They would just fucking deload your
brain and turn you into a robot.
That's what they would do.
They've already need to be turned into
robot.
The NSA came out today.
There was an article that said the NSA
has 100 percent access to iphones.
They can look at your camera,
read your texts,
listened to your microphone,
like,
keep your microphone on.
Even if your phone is off.
Is that a surprise to people?
Um,
that 100 percent access?
That's pretty fascinating.
The thing about,
and this is one of the reasons why our
podcast sponsors sponsored by Ting
tings,
a company that uses android phones and
what I like to get an android.
What I like about android phones.
Yeah,
you've got an android.
You can take the battery out so you can
shut it off.
Not saying that the government is really
listening to you,
but the idea that that's possible that
anybody can just turn your microphone on
it anytime or turn your camera on at
anytime.
To me sounds ridiculous,
but we know that the NSA has that
capability.
If you have an android phone and you
just take the battery out,
can't do that with an iphone.
I found some weird,
a lot of weird shit about the iphone.
The memory is all in there.
You can't get it out.
The fucking the batteries in there and
can't get it out.
No accidents are dying.
Know people are dying.
Making those killing themselves.
You know what's hilarious about that?
I had this conversation with guy who was
trying.
I have a friend than not a good friend,
but this guy that I know that always
tries to give me the republican point of
view on things like he's a sensible
logical guy,
know we were talking about this factory
in China where people are jumping off
the roof and he goes,
well,
do you know how many people are working
at that factory?
And uh,
I said,
yeah,
I just like about half a million people
or something crazy.
And he goes,
and if you look at the average
population of a half a million people,
the amount of suicides is pretty
standard.
And I said,
yeah,
but they're killing themselves at work.
How many fucking people killed
themselves at work?
Like that's not standard is nothing
standard about that.
That's ridiculous that that concept is
ridiculous.
Idiot talk or say it's like a fucking a
tower of bullshit.
There's a lot of people that don't want
to be silly though.
You know what I mean?
They want to be sensible.
Come on.
We have enough fact and data now that we
can make informed decisions.
W W we have enough stuff to make
informed intelligence,
intelligent decisions that work for the,
you know,
the p for everyone,
not just the few at the expense of the
many but for everyone and um,
you know,
that I feel like,
hey,
you know,
yeah,
we're on our way out and everything's
fucked up and dying and over,
but I think it's our Karma to fucking do
it right this time because,
uh,
you know,
helping each other and such,
trying to,
um,
take a step back from needing so much
and being more into sharing and new
thoughts,
new solutions,
solution based thinking and stuff.
I think this is a great time for that
and we're,
we're really evolving into that and
people can't back away from it anymore.
So it's not over.
Well,
I,
I think that,
you know,
I do think it's over first humans,
but I think that when people get that in
their head,
it's going to make them really mutate
quickly and go,
oh my God,
uh,
I better get right with my maker and
actually start fucking doing some of the
shit that I know is,
you know,
the right thing to do just because I'm a
human being.
Right.
I think that's happening.
I think that's happening as well.
That's why I have hope.
I think that's evident in what I read
online.
I mean even points that I don't agree
with the extreme left points,
the extreme progressive positions,
which a lot of times I don't take those
positions,
but I liked the fact that those
positions are really public now.
You know,
what I like is how the left.
Uh,
I like how I like to watch it on
twitter,
you know,
I like how the left light goes,
right for character assassination,
but then,
you know,
that's what people do when they've lost
the argument.
Add homonyms.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
sometimes it's,
they're good points though.
It's a good to consider how fucked up
someone else before you listen to their
point of view on something.
If you know that they're kicking babies
in their spare time,
it's probably something to pay attention
to.
I know what you mean though.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm just trying to say like,
just because somebody,
you know,
they're trying to.
The real thing is that they want the
monopoly of definition.
That's what they're after.
That's the real war.
They want things to mean what they want
them.
That's a very good try to censor people
who are saying something else.
That's a very powerful statement.
What you said,
the monopoly of,
of definition.
That's so,
so true.
And I've never
tried to censor that debate in a free
society.
We have debate which has more than one
opinion.
Yes.
Your mindset.
I'm like Monsanto Science.
It's the same mental thing and uh,
you know,
uh,
it's a rigid ideology.
Yeah.
And it makes no sense.
It doesn't,
it doesn't apply data and fact as it,
it doesn't directly apply data and
facts.
What's also,
I think there's a lot of these people
that are involved in both sides,
whether it's the conservative movement
for sure,
or the really progressive movement that
are really just assholes that want to
get heard.
I really just love giving their opinion
and they love the attention that even if
they have a point,
well that's part of MK Ultra mind
control.
You say it is what I liked that.
How many times do you use the word
binary because that it is a binary.
And uh,
what Mk ultra does is it's like these
two groups there,
they're like,
you know,
they both work for the same people.
They both get paid from the same people,
the Democrats and the Republicans.
And what they do is they use monopoly.
They tried to monopolize the definition
so they can fundraise.
And I say it's like the fundraising.
Those parties are the fundraising arm of
the prison,
military media,
wedding,
industrial complex,
you know,
I mean,
they just want to confuse people so that
people vote against their own better
judgment and their own best interests.
And that's their strategy.
That's their whole mk alter strategy.
How they get people to stop thinking
that they deserve an answer and a
solution for the tax monies they pay.
That is what the tea party was
originally about before it got waylaid
by punk ass hoes.
Well,
isn't that what always happens?
So occupy Wall Street,
they said at one point in time they
think that one of the three people in
occupy Wall Street was really like FBI.
They're really like some undercover
agents.
They infiltrate and doesn't that happen
with everything that happened with the
tea party as well.
The people that thought that the tea
party was like,
look,
we're gonna demand a responsible
government and a government that follows
the constitution.
Then all of a sudden these crazy Fox got
involved in racism and nuttiness yeah.
What better way to diffuse a movement
then to make to marginalize them by
making them look ridiculous?
Well,
they do send in their people and I'm
always have always will
monopoly of definition again.
And it is that.
Then they can control their own
opposition and you know,
you know,
that works at that work.
That's how power does it.
That's what ideologies due to the
monopoly of definition that you
described,
which is such a great phrase again.
Um,
but that,
that's,
that is the issue with the left.
That's the issue with the right.
That's the issue with having teams is
like you decide that this is how we look
at things and how we look at things is
how they are.
Well,
uh,
the left does it for a certain reason
because that's how they fundraise out of
like the,
like the leather bags,
like the Democrats begged for money.
It's like we need $3 by midnight.
Have you gotten those emails are not a
part of that list.
And uh,
you know,
they're begging for money and the
Republicans,
like they begged for money too,
but they demand it,
like they have the right to it because
its sovereignty that they're defending
but they're not.
They're frigging yanking people to get
their money.
That's all they're doing.
Both of them.
They work together.
They are a system of mind control that
helps them move public money into
private pockets.
It's so fucking ridiculous.
I mean,
I feel sorry for people that they have
been so manipulated and you know,
all the time they're losing everything.
Yeah,
no,
it's horrible that it's.
It is,
it's a,
it's a disgusting aspect of human beings
and a weird thing where we're tribal
people and I think ultimately we have
that instinct to be a part of a group
and when people are part of that group,
you see this group think is so strong.
It's so prevalent.
I've had conversations with people about
anything.
I had a conversation with a guy who I,
you know,
before this conversation I respected
them online will about um,
abortion where the Richard Dawkins it
said that a,
um,
a fetus inside a woman's body is like
less human than,
uh,
than,
than a pig is,
you know,
I go just as human as a peer,
that Dale Carnegie Book,
it was just a weird.
It's a weird statement.
And I,
I,
I took,
I tweeted,
well,
that's silly because everyone knows that
a fetus can become a human being.
All right?
That's the idea behind the abortion.
Like you're being very disingenuous if
you pretended the idea behind the
abortion isn't that what you're doing is
you're stopping a potential human being.
A pig is not,
you're not going to stop.
It's going to become a person.
It's not.
It doesn't turn into a carriage or a
fucking pumpkin.
Alright?
It's a pig of a fetus is a part of a
person that has nothing to do with a
woman's right.
To choose the woman's right to choose as
a completely different time.
So he starts calling me a Republican and
saying like,
you know that I,
I don't respect.
Isn't this all about controlling a
woman's body?
Like.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
No,
they want you to say what they are
saying.
Yay.
They had a bunch of fucking.
And they want to diffuse anything that
you're saying that might be logical.
Their economies to.
There's a lot of that.
It is
like,
um,
you know,
you know it.
It's just like,
it's going to go my way or the highway.
We don't allow you.
To me,
it's like this.
We don't allow old women or open their
fucking mouth and in the general
theater.
Excuse me,
bitch.
That's what it feels like to me.
So that's why I just go,
well,
you wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Well,
with this guy that I was talking to,
I don't think it was that.
I think it was he was just following the
ideology.
You,
you're always supposed to support a
woman's right to choose and you're
always supposed to marginalize any,
uh,
anything that would point to the idea of
abortion being a bad thing.
And I'm saying they're not mutually
exclusive.
Like I think a woman should be.
We'll do whatever she wants to do with
our body.
I can't control that,
but it does get crazy when you're
talking about a boarding,
an eight month old fetus.
I mean,
at what point in time,
when does it get crazy?
It's not crazy when it's a group of
cells.
I agree.
You're pulling out a group of cells.
Is it crazy ones that big?
Is it crazy when it's that big?
Is it crazy one?
It can exist outside of your body is.
I mean,
I don't know
this,
but to say that this is not a discussion
for today.
Huge,
a huge subject.
It needs a lot of debate and you know,
you have to look at what's being
censored and there's a reason why it's
being censored.
People are uncomfortable with it.
There are also uncomfortable with their
decision that,
you know,
they want to be able to have an
abortion.
Then if you say,
well,
okay,
you know,
you're killing a potential human being.
Like,
oh no,
no,
I'm getting ringing some cells.
Okay.
At what point in time has it become a
person is that's an actual conversation.
I think that's a real conversation to,
to pretend that it's not,
is a part of that whole ideology thing.
It's a part of that thing where people
as your fucking phone going off your
kids going,
mom,
the CIA's at the house.
Wait a minute,
I just got to say I'm on the radio.
I'll call you.
Are you okay?
Wait,
I told him I was going on here anyway.
Sorry.
It tells a fucking stupid and it could
like.
It has a simple solution like for people
like me,
like we we think different than other
people,
but we can see that there's a simple and
much cheaper solution to all of these
problems.
You know,
if if logic,
data and fact are applied,
I think there are being applied now more
than ever before and that's why I have
hope.
And then also I think this idea of teams
of a Republican left wing Democrat or
Democrat,
left wing Republican,
right wing that's looking more and more
silly every day,
especially when you look at Obama,
there's so many people that fucking
support Obama and don't say God damn
thing about the shit that he's done in
comparison to the shit that we're on
Bush about the same stuff,
same stuff,
and all these liberals have proven to be
massive cowards by not coming out
against him the way they came out
against Bush on
million different things.
They may be.
You have to look at what happens to you
when you do that.
You know how it works.
Twitter activism as it's called,
it's just character assassination.
You ruined fucking people's lives
because their opinion isn't in line with
your sanction opinion that you were paid
to get out there and lobby.
You know,
I mean,
seriously,
people's lives are ruined if they stand
up against power.
Let's not forget that.
Oh,
for sure.
If it's a massive amount of pallets
after whistleblowers.
Now isn't that fascinating that he,
in his case,
the campaign website,
there was a whole thing about giving
whistleblowers relief and,
and helping them expose injustices and
then they yanked all that shit out.
What to say though?
They knew who they knew,
you know?
What do you think does,
what do you think that is?
Do you think that once you get into
office they just,
they let you know what the real deal is.
You can talk all that shit you want
while you're campaigning,
but once you get into office then you
find out what the fuck's up.
You know,
I think it's the system.
The system is what's corrupt,
that people are just stuck in the
system.
I think if the system were changed,
if you know,
and it would have to be changed by the
people and the People's government,
the people's application of there.
Well that would result in accurate
government,
you know,
for the people.
I think,
you know,
I think without that it will continue to
replicate no matter who's there because
it's stupid and it doesn't work.
It's fucking passe.
It's obsolete as time for fucking,
you know,
to stop defending what's already fucking
dead so you can yank people and get them
to send you fucking money.
You know,
I think we should just be done with
money.
Serious W we don't fucking need money.
And you know what?
People don't need gold either.
They need water.
So let's make water the new fucking
currency or something.
Oh,
let's move away from it.
It ain't that hard.
It's not that hard to create a fucking
just economic money system.
It's still have rich fucking people too.
How do you have rich people have this no
money?
Well,
you know,
you would have other means to create
Commonwealth and so some people would
accrue more,
but it wasn't about the money when that
would be necessarily.
I completely agree with you that the
system is fucked and I think that
patching it up is like taking a,
a windows 95 computer and trying to make
it work in today's Internet and fucking
adding a bunch of shit to it and
tweaking.
It's a broken system.
Throw it out and get a new one.
We're smart enough.
We get enough smart fucking people that
they can put something better together.
We could do a lot better in a big fat
fucking hurry if we shut the fuck up and
mind our own God damn business.
Stay home once in a while and uh,
you know,
clean up your own back fucking yard.
What do you think is the best example of
a working government in this,
in this planet?
Is there one country that really stands
out as really having their shit
together?
Norway or Sweden.
I'm like an Iceland because I'm always
like,
what the fuck am I going to go look
around?
But I sign,
yeah,
because because
they,
they dumped the Fed and then they
started arresting bankers and doing
something different and they got richer
for doing it because they're not
imposing a system of dead on people
there are doing something smarter and
you know,
I mean,
I just have hope that that would happen
here because we could,
we could nationalize the Federal Reserve
and solve,
solve all our problems was saved the
dollar.
But I mean nobody will frigging do it.
Yeah,
I know.
I agree with you about Iceland as well.
I think that is also,
if there's an example of a one country
that can do it,
those are people.
And so that's a better.
That's a clear example that your,
what your statement is,
that the system is corrupt.
Well that's proof right there because
you're seeing a system that's not
corrupt and the people are benefiting
from it and it's a healthy society.
People,
everything will work just fine.
Everything knows what it's supposed to
do already.
If you just get the fucking people that
are,
you know,
fucking it up out of the way.
And the best way to get them out of the
way,
in my opinion,
is to remind them that they can rejoin
the human race.
They don't have to be on that other
side.
And you know,
in that limbo exile thing that I know
they live in because I've seen it,
they can rejoin it and then fucking come
up with a solution that actually works.
It ain't that fucking hard.
I think people are doing shit like
grandmas,
all of this world.
They're fixing their community with a
rubber band and a paperclip.
It's not that fucking hard to have
everything work.
Well,
the default position of the universe is
to the positive.
Everything fucking already knows what to
do except for,
you know,
criminals at the top,
a small group of criminals at the top.
I think you're a hundred percent right.
And I think that I like in our society
that have like an alcoholics
personality,
someone who's trapped in a terrible
pattern keeps repeating the same
problems over and over again and
drinking and driving and know just
fucking killing their body.
I think that that probably is how our
society is,
that we've got addicted to the idea of
extracting money out of this broken
system to the point where people are so
addicted to money and so addicted to the
benefits of having it,
that they're not willing to say,
hey,
you know,
I'm a part of something that's
ultimately destructive even to me and to
my children.
That gambling mentality,
this people think they're.
If people think they're getting
something for nothing,
that's like the greatest frigging drug.
They,
they disguise what it is,
but it's thinking you're going to get
more than everybody else.
That's so true that they'd love.
People love getting over,
don't they?
They love it.
They love getting over.
I have a friend that will like try to
get bargains on fucking everything and
I'm like,
dude,
you have money.
Like why are you haggling over,
you know,
an extra $20 off or something or $5 off
or whatever the fuck it is.
Because I like getting over.
I just like getting over.
He goes,
if I can get it for free,
I'd want to get it for free.
Like people want to get free and they're
rich.
They do.
They want that thrill of figuring out
how I got rich.
So I know firsthand how it works on you.
I know exactly how it works on you,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Well,
and it works on you.
It does tell there's,
you know,
there's nothing left of you.
And that's a
hard.
That's a hard thing.
That's hard when you can't fucking
stomach get no more,
but then you can let go,
oh,
I'm going to not do that no more.
You was,
it hard going from like not having money
to be in like one of the richest women
in the history of Hollywood over a
period the world over a period of how
many years?
Uh,
three years.
That's insane isn't it?
Was fucking charging right away.
When I first came to La,
my first night there,
like they saw me that I got a TV show
the first night there.
Then I got the tonight show,
then I got a Julio Iglesias tour that
was 10 times the money my husband worked
in the Boston office ever made.
So,
you know,
I mean,
it was chaching right from the get go in
La dream come true,
you know?
Wow.
And you were one of the old school
comedy store gangsters till you came up
in the era where things were probably
one of the most powerful errors in the
history of standup comedy.
If you go back and look at like the
origins from Lenny Bruce Harland,
to what have you,
your era of the comedy store is one of
the most powerful areas ever.
Yeah,
it has.
But there was one that proceeded me
that,
that was the one where,
um,
you know,
they had the strike and all the comics.
I mean,
there was a like,
oh,
David Steinberg and you know,
those guys,
they're like in their seventies,
late seventies now.
But a whole bunch of guys like that.
Um,
Oh God,
I'm so bad on names.
I remember us.
But you know,
I'm a whole Elayne boosler just a little
bit before me.
They,
they were the ones that created it broke
down,
you know?
So they did great work.
Great.
Yeah.
For folks who don't know,
the way La Works is,
for the longest time nobody got paid.
You would go up and you would do spots
and the clubs,
would it be packed every night and the
comedians will be starving to death,
especially the local ones that are just
sorta start now,
but they would be providing,
providing all this entertainment but not
sharing any of the profit.
And this,
the comedy clubs weren't willing to
budge.
They,
they were like,
look,
this is the way it is.
There was a book that is written on it,
right?
Irish should fear was reading it
recently.
I forget what it's called.
See what you find that Jimmy.
Um,
but the,
uh,
the strike itself was,
was very important and now comedians get
paid for their sets.
It's kind of weird that they would think
that it would be okay to have people
perform and you profit off them
performing,
but you keep all the money.
Well,
we saw that in Denver too.
We had a,
we had a little club there and everybody
worked for free.
And the owner's like,
start buying second homes and you know,
I'm dying up here.
That's the name of the book.
Oh yeah,
I have that.
You know,
when you see the owner who's another
comic and he's buying a second house and
uh,
you know,
adding on to the club,
you're like any still doing time on
Monday
on.
He's still working in the club,
you know,
I mean they think they're doing you some
good by letting you performed.
That's what they said to us.
More like,
you know what you're going to pay.
And because they won in La,
they did.
So it went all across.
It went all across the country that,
that ripple of that.
But the idea behind is pretty fucking
gross.
And you know the adjust because the
comics are benefiting from it.
What you're not like that is your whole
business.
Well that's profit sharing again and
commonwealth and all that same stuff at
any club owner that will do,
that's a piece of shit.
And he club owner that wouldn't want to
compensate the comedians that are
performing from.
I actually think that you're going to
get them to work for free while you have
your place packed every fucking night.
It's disgusting.
Like you don't feel they're going to get
a lot out or they're going to get
famous,
you know,
that's like all artists in Hollywood
know.
I mean anybody who can put two words
together,
you know,
they,
they'd rather not pay you a dime of
writers,
musicians,
songwriters,
you know,
they want to own everything now.
They got their copyright laws,
they want on everything.
Some people do,
but there's one of the beautiful things
about small clubs that I've always loved
to,
you know,
if I'll do like xannies in Nashville or
something like that.
It's like the club owners,
if you go to these places,
like they actually liked the art form.
They will.
It's a good exchange.
They enjoy it,
you know,
the,
the enjoy the idea of having performers
on the stage and the people have a good
time and that their business flourishes.
They're happy to pay you.
Well,
you know,
there's a lot of great comics out there
getting old now and you know,
they don't have any money and there's a
bunch of shit like that.
They gave their whole lives for comedy
and they didn't get rich like I did,
you know,
and a few of us,
but they're just as you know,
they're great writers,
great comics,
but you know,
you get broke down by that system,
like all artists and creative people do
well.
I think we're a lot of these guys too
though.
They're also very,
woe is me as a quote.
Quite a few of those guys that never
figured out social media,
they never figured out how to promote
themselves.
They stop writing new material and then
they,
they feel like I've been doing standup
for 30 years.
I can't sell at a club.
Well,
well,
what did you do?
I mean like what did you do with your
time?
Like how much of your time did you
actually invest in continuing your
career?
How much of your time did you actually
invest in writing and how much did you
just think that it was just due to you?
Because you've been around for 30 years.
I thought it was just due to me.
You sound like my representatives now.
Well,
for you,
you know you.
I've said it before the show,
but I'll say it afterwards so other
people could hear.
We were talking recently about 10 of the
most influential comedians of all time
and you are our list and I appreciate
that.
Thank you.
It's 100 percent true.
It's an honor to have you on the show.
In fact,
I think that you came along and you were
this new type of woman stand up in the
ways.
Even more powerful than kinison was as a
male standup.
You came along and you had this whole
new thing going on and you were a woman
who didn't give a fuck.
Like you don't give a fuck what anybody
says.
You gotTa fucking tell him and he's
going to say like,
shut the fuck up.
This is what I feel.
This is my fucking
husband.
And you would.
You were slaying with this material
because nobody had ever seen that
before.
I remember thing was my mom who told me
about you pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure it was my mom because my
mom,
she likes to stay in her sixties.
Yes.
And she likes stand up and uh,
I think she was,
I'm almost positive it was her,
but she's like,
you gotta see this woman?
Oh my God.
She made me laugh like no woman has ever
made me laugh.
But that statement,
like it was a different kind of a thing.
Like she said it that way.
I mean she was just,
just trying to say how much he enjoyed
it,
but that was a true statement.
Like she made you laugh in a way that
you never laughed at a woman comic
before you just,
you owned it.
Were a lot of these women who came
before you.
Although we're very funny.
They wanted people to like them and you
were like,
fuck you guys.
I learned it.
I mean,
you know,
I learned that on stage.
I'll tell Ya.
I did learn a lot of it from my dad
because my dad was just like that.
He was like one of the funniest ones
ever.
Really?
Yeah.
But he had to get a job,
you know,
because he had kids.
So,
but uh,
and he did some funny,
funny,
did you stand up nowhere near the house
and when people called Israel always had
the mormons.
We lived in Salt Lake in the Mormons
always came to our house to teach us
about,
you know,
the book of Mormon and my mom was a nice
woman so she always let a man and I
guess you want somebody to talk to or
whatever it plus they were handsome as
hell.
And my mom's like that pretty girl
always.
So she's like,
when she was 70 she like,
I can still get a man.
Whoa man.
Whoa.
So that's why I'm so neurotic because.
So she would invite a man.
And so my dad,
he didn't like him because he was an
atheist.
So he used to go down the basement and
scream up a bar.
The better thing he did was when they
knock on the door after they'd been
there a couple times.
He goes,
Mrs Barr in?
And he goes,
Mrs Barr,
Mrs Barr is in jail for 28 days.
We have nothing to discuss it and we ask
kids are just wouldn't be pee in our
pants.
So who does do that to fuck with people
to entertain?
He,
uh,
the heart of a standup,
right?
Yeah.
Plus his lines were pretty good too.
Yeah,
he was funny.
My whole family was funny.
It was all slams.
Every slamming,
everybody.
I got the first slam when I was four.
My uncle Sherman was sitting there
eating my grandma's soup and he always
called her a greenhorn,
the self care.
She was an immigrant and so he's like,
you know,
in America they don't put an inch of
chicken fat on top of their soap.
I was like four and I think he's talking
about by grandma and I really want to
film this too because I felt like wonder
woman and I knew I was going to deliver
the.
It
came to me and I was going to do it,
you know,
that thing you get when you a comic.
And I'm like,
then how come you eat two bowls of it?
Boom.
And,
and everyone laughed and he got really
pissed that I was only four,
but he got pissed.
So then I was like,
oh boy,
I can own this room.
So you remember the first time you ever
killed?
Yeah,
I do.
I remember every section you just
knocked out of the park and you had the
feeling that you get when you go on
stage and you have an idea because he
was fat and no one could say he was fat.
They couldn't say,
hey,
you're a tub or anything like that to
him because he was sensitive.
But he was a bully.
Like a lot of fat people are bullies,
you know,
they're not all jolly well there's a lot
of fat people that are uncomfortable,
right?
Yeah.
Whatever.
But they're mean and he's the one of
them.
So I was like,
you're eating too much.
UHM,
it was like double and I knew it was
fucking Delta because it was like I was,
I was penetrating the shield of
bullshit.
We don't tell him he fucking is a big
fat pig.
The best comedy law.
It's so fun.
Missile.
A hell fire missile that penetrates the
shield of bullshit.
The bad thing is when you are like that,
like me and my dad given it back.
Then you have kids and they give it to
you and the God damn it.
It's awful.
My kid already gives it to her.
How long have a five and a three.
The five year olds already like talk
shit.
It's so you're covering.
It's totally.
I told her she had to go to bed.
She goes,
well,
I don't have a job.
She just looked at me,
was say daddy has to get up in the
morning.
That has a job.
I got to go to sleep zone.
So when I tell her she got to go to
sleep.
She was like,
well,
I don't know what job being just looking
at me.
I was like,
Oh snap.
This is before she was even going to
preschool.
She was four when she said that,
I know it's happening.
I know it's coming,
but that's no way around it.
Karma and no parent escapes it.
I enjoy it.
I wanted to be.
I want her to be strong.
I want her to have her own opinions and
I mean the arguing about whether or not
she should have to go to bed is the
beginning of arguing whether or not she
should have a terrible job arguing
whether she should have an existence
that she doesn't enjoy,
whether she should have been in a
relationship that you think sucks to
said.
Got a good point.
I said,
well,
yeah.
I mean I told her go to bed.
No,
no.
I made her watch one more half hour of
Max and Ruby and then go to bed.
Give her 30 minutes.
I didn't tell her that the line deserves
reward because I didn't want her to be
encouraged to continue it,
but I just had explained it to her.
I said,
it's so important when you're young to
get your sleep.
I go,
because you're a growing organism,
you know,
so I tried to explain like,
showed her some pictures when she was a
baby.
I said,
you see what you look like now or you
don't look like that anymore.
That's all from sleep.
That sleep turns you from a baby into
this four year old girl.
Can Talk to me.
She was like,
really?
I go,
Yup.
it's thinking and it's learning.
That's all important too.
But sleep is big.
It's really important.
I go,
but it's not going to hurt you if you
watch one more show.
So we'll watch one more.
Good Dad.
It's so.
It's so important that girls have a good
dad that they can talk to.
Girls need that more.
More than anything.
I think so.
And it's important for God to have a
good mom.
You know,
something funny.
My Dad said,
I,
we are Jews,
you know,
in Salt Lake.
And I said,
I was like,
how come Santa doesn't come to our
house?
I was like,
I was about eight,
maybe six.
How come?
How come it doesn't come over our house?
Because Santa is an antisemite.
It was so funny.
Horrible thing for a kid to hear.
It was hilarious.
You already knew you enjoyed it.
You were like,
are raised to be a comic essentially.
He used to watch Ed Sullivan with me,
you know,
and he'd go,
this guy is a,
he's a comic.
He says,
you know,
he's,
he goes,
this guy's a comedian.
He,
he says things funny.
This guy is a comic.
He says,
funny things.
He told me,
he broke it all down for me.
He goes,
this guy is actively resisting.
This guy has a resistor.
This guy is a,
um,
what do you call it,
where you collude because he has,
you know,
he was like a big fucking commy.
Your Dad was a big comedy.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
he grew up during the McCarthy era,
which,
I mean,
you want it to be a comic because you
didn't want to be the fucking government
usually thought that was good.
The opposite side when you've got these
people that are getting arrested because
they went to a meeting and talk to
people about socialism.
So they're getting arrested and they're
getting blacklisted from Hollywood.
They getting their fucking jobs taken
away from them for going to meetings and
talking to people about ideas.
That blacklisting thing and the left
joins in on it.
If you'll notice that the left joins in
on the,
on,
like I was pretty shocked that they were
coming after him.
You know,
the Times that they've come after me
because you didn't understand a couple
of times I've said stupid things and uh,
oh,
I'm not getting into it.
You don't get into it.
Why would I do that?
Just as an example.
So if people don't know that are
listening to this,
they would like to know what you mean
by.
Well,
because me,
I don't know.
I got in a fight with the transgenders,
the transgenders.
What was it about all of them?
Not all of them.
The majority of them are,
are Nice,
wonderful people.
They really are.
And I know a lot of them,
but you know,
assholes are in every group.
What you were talking about tribalism.
Here's no family.
Say when they pervert tribalism and
here's what they do too.
They make him defend everybody who's
like you,
but that's not good because you're the
Predator right
there.
Sure.
The Predator is the one every group
should be against.
It is time to read every community,
every type,
every,
every street of predators who liked aid
people taking people's money,
taking public money and putting it in
private pockets,
right?
Yes.
I agree.
One hundred percent is saying that all
people have this nationality,
those are my people or all people with
this gender.
Those are my people or all people that
are transgender are my people.
It's all equally ridiculous.
Everybody's got households in their
group.
Just be anti asshole would be.
I could not agree more and that has
always been my problem with the idea of
feminism.
You know,
like I'm 100 percent for equality for
and I think that we should look down on
men who were abusing women the same way
we look down on women abusing men the
same way we look at men abusing men the
same way we look at women abusing women.
It's a gross thing that humans do where
they victimize each other.
That's exactly right.
And there should be one fucking way to
go.
One law for everybody that gets rid of
all that,
rest of that shit.
They just fundraising again that these
fucking people,
they're fundraising.
Well,
it could be that.
It's also the need to be,
you know,
you're not on my team.
Fuck you.
This people that are only team,
att and t,
what are you going with?
Rosen.
Oh,
you're using a windows computer.
You push.
You need to get a Mac.
You know,
people are crazy.
They're crazy with that.
They're getting paid to do that though.
That's a natural.
Oh,
they absolutely do.
They have,
I think almost all do this fucking
Chevy.
People that have a car,
they have the Calvin and Hobbes of a,
uh,
Calvin pissing on a Ford logo because
they don't like for
people retarded.
They just go with these stupid team.
I'm from Milwaukee.
We don't give a fuck about being from
Chicago.
That's a statement that a person in
Milwaukee is likely to say.
If you bring up Chicago Patrick
mentality,
it's,
it's a natural thing.
It's being taught.
I'm not going to agree with you.
That's why I don't have any.
You do have hope?
I do,
but I have a different kind of hope
because my hopes based on my helping
other human beings.
So as is mine,
as his mom,
I don't have like any umbrella fucking
hope that the right thing is going to
happen as people are fucking stupid.
That's what they are.
They're stupid in their followers and
they are too busy to think,
but they're also beautiful and
brilliant.
The reason why we're having this
conversation at all is because someone
figured out a way to put all this
electronics shit into this tube that's
only like six inches long and then it's
attached to this wire that's attached to
a fucking computer as a distribution
vehicle for information than I would
have never been able to figure out on
my.
Okay,
wait a minute.
I want to say you're changing the
subject.
I want to say this.
I don't believe that people are fucked
up.
I don't believe that they have,
that they are a slave to their worst
impulses.
I don't.
I think some are more,
but I think the majority of people are
not like that.
I think the majority of people are
actually good,
but they are for people kept away from
the seats of power and if we could just
get one.
One of them somewhere,
anywhere,
Yemen,
anywhere one of them will will,
will change it.
Everything.
Just one intelligent person.
I,
I think one intelligent person can reach
all intelligence,
even in the greediest lowest a backward
bastard on earth.
I think you're 100 percent right.
I also think that that noise is going to
drive people crazy.
What is that?
Is that you banging on this thing?
Someone next door to someone next door.
What are they doing?
They're making something that's loud as
fuck.
They're probably are listening to the
podcast and they hate me banging on my
door because they know it's next door.
They have cake.
Maybe it's a CIA,
setting up a listening station.
How many good people there are in our
government and people report this to me.
I just want to say this to people.
They do report to me that there,
there are good people everywhere.
I'm sure there's good people in our
government and they're like,
right now they're proving that because
of they had solutions that made common
sense to people.
They're being promoted and getting
closer to a logical seats of power.
So I think that
good to,
well I think that this is what I was
saying when I did the Internet and that
the,
the transparency of information that we
have today is going to sort of reinforce
those ideas.
If you're going to represent people,
you have to represent them in a way that
benefits the people and that's possible.
It's possible to do so.
Uh,
we're,
we're both on the same page.
Just a little more extreme than me.
Yeah.
Chem trails and stuff.
And Mk Ultra and aliens.
That's where you draw the line I think.
I think there might be row.
I think there might be robots.
I think the news might all be
manufactured outside,
that's pretty sure in a studio.
And.
And they probably have lookalikes
playing the party.
Did you see wag the dog?
Yes,
I did.
It was.
And that was a long time ago,
by the way,
before they had the kind of CGI that
they have today.
Well,
I think they're definitely fake some
stuff.
The CIA printed in the paper during the
beginning of the Iraq invasion that they
were going to release fake stories.
It was on CNN,
they were going to release fake stories
for the good of,
you know,
uh,
the troops or whatever the fuck it was,
you know,
like that's it when you're admitting
them,
destroying their records,
that's what people who believe the tower
seven thing was the tower seven
confusion or I'm a conspiracy rather,
is that there was so much evidence
inside that building that could have
fucked them bank stuff and Ron and ron
stuff and it was the
CIA had offices in that building.
The NSA had offices in that building.
That building was a crazy fucking
building of information and shit.
That was the black male center maybe.
I don't know what the fuck it was,
but I know that that building imploded.
Lucky it was detonated those,
those other two buildings to me look
like buildings.
I got hit by a plane and horrible
structural damage and everything fell
because they failed the way something
would fall.
It was collapsing and falling apart.
That tower seven thing felt like it was
a controlled demolition.
Now,
obviously I'm not an engineer,
nor I'm an architect or a construction
expert,
so I don't know if a fire could make a
building do that.
It might be able to because look,
the things or weird things,
it's.
It's weird to be able to detonate a
building in the first place.
It's weird when you see,
you know,
sometimes shit happens.
Sometimes things don't go the way you
would think they would go through lack
of management.
There is a of what they think it is.
It's like people are swimming in theory.
Yeah.
Well,
it's one of those things.
It's so.
It's,
it's also so enticing to believe that
tower seven was the place where they
were holding all this information and
they detonated in front of everybody's
eyes on television.
Like Holy Shit.
They got away with it because it's,
you know,
if you were inclined to lean towards
that,
that would be one of the possibilities.
The reality is,
I don't know.
I,
here's what I got out of it.
Okay,
well get here.
We can watch it.
We get to watch it fall.
Okay,
I'll get that five seconds.
Watch it again.
Play that,
play that again,
because it's,
it's anybody that says it's not weird.
Is hilarious.
Office is that seven,
whatever it is,
it's free fall speed.
That's one of the things that they did
prove and they tried to argue it,
which is hilarious.
The nist guys tried to argue that it
wasn't free fall speed.
They tried to say that,
uh,
it was like a second slower than free.
False.
Be like you're talking about the
collapse of a building.
Like even if it's a second flow is
slower than free fall speed.
That's fucking crazy.
That thing just imploded into its own
base.
Watch it one more time.
Look at that.
Ooh,
look how it does that.
Anybody that doesn't think that's nuts.
Your nut.
That's the set there.
You know how when they go like this on
the side and they take it down?
Yeah.
Like the,
the,
yeah,
the set and uh,
on a screen or a stage for a play
people,
except for the people who survived on
the streets.
The horror of that.
That's really what it was about.
I thought.
But also the thing I knew it was the
fucking end of the world when I say that
because it was like I couldn't believe
it because all these guys in suits,
they were lined up on the sides of the
roads and they were applauding for the
firemen and the workers who do the
actual work and they were like handing
them water and I went,
this is the fucking end of the world.
Americans are actually like applauding
the way things actually work.
The guys in the suits or actually
applauding the first responders and
stuff.
I thought this has got
to be that.
This is the hand of the bullshit.
Just bullshit.
Met the touch,
you know the.
What do they say meets the road?
Do you remember those days?
Like right after nine slash 11.
Oh yeah.
Those are crazy days.
There's a weird feeling in the air,
wasn't it?
It was like.
It was also a weird comradery between
Americans.
Like everywhere you go,
everybody had American flags on their
cars.
It was nuts,
but it was for the right stuff.
At first it was like they were taking
know they were bringing water and they
were bringing supplies and it was like,
we're gonna fucking,
we're going.
It was like really amazing because it's
like we're going to win out of goodness
and,
and that's how it felt then.
And it was like,
you know,
that people were like,
they were so good and they were so
caring and they were coming together
against a common foe.
Yeah.
And the,
the,
the love of the first responders to.
That was a big thing when I was in New
York in 2002 and I couldn't believe how
nice people were being the cops and
firemen like yelling out to him,
waving to him,
honking their horns,
saying we love you.
Just,
it was crazy.
It was like you could feel the tangible
result of them realizing like,
wow,
like we're in a situation where we were,
we got attacked like,
and these are the people that saved
people and you know,
there's this weird feeling of mortality
now and a real risk
New York when I was driving down the
street,
because I'm always watching people,
you know.
And uh,
it was watching people walking down the
street after that for quite some time,
maybe six months,
a few times I checked it.
They were actually making eye contact
with other people and smiling.
And then like a few years later,
you know,
after the Bush,
the whole thing there,
they were back to just the looking
straight down thing and avoiding eye
contact.
But it was like,
wow,
that was a mind meld going on.
It was like a positive love mindmeld
thing.
Yeah.
It only lasted for a little while.
Right.
How long did it last?
Last few years
lasted until Bush got up there and,
you know,
what did that act,
that sketch?
Yeah.
One where he went on the boat.
Mission accomplished.
Yeah.
I think people also realize that this
was a,
that the powers that be had capitalized
on all this,
you know,
this,
this sort of patriotism and all this,
uh,
there's this enthusiasm and America had
for revenge and
yeah,
first thing they cut the benefits of the
street.
It's like,
wow,
that's why I thought,
well,
last did Wall Street and do it,
do you think?
But nine slash 11,
I think that nine slash 11 more likely
than not was the result of a bunch of
terrorists that attacked America.
And why did they do it?
Most likely because of what America has
been doing overseas,
you know,
we create enemies.
We do it from the beginning.
We've done it from the beginning of
time.
Every nation that's been in power has
always tried to steal the natural
resources of other nations.
As A.
I've always tried to influence the
governments of other nations and there's
a blowback from that shit.
You know,
the people think that they know that was
the most embarrassing and I'm in
enraging thing about what the Bush
administration,
the way they would flavor it,
they hate us for our freedom.
But he actually said that on TV once.
They hate us for our freedom.
But who is he talking to?
You talking about the terrorists?
No,
he's talking to the people he
represents,
which are they investor classes?
He said it himself and they and people
do hate their freedom because it's their
freedom to be predators.
I think he was talking,
I was talking to.
I think he was talking to the duck
dynasty fans are fucking stupid and they
were Rah Rah,
and they didn't want to put any thought
to it though he hate us for our freedom
and they're like,
let's go get some.
That's what he was doing.
I think he was just patronizing
knuckleheads and that this idea that
somehow or another people wouldn't like
that people are having a good time
somewhere.
So they're willing to kill themselves by
flying fucking planes into buildings.
This,
it's insulting.
Well,
I mean that's one way of looking at it.
You know,
I've heard a lot of opinion,
another band,
Jesus,
you know,
now what has happened all over the world
is now happening in our country.
You know,
you know,
there was a lot of that.
Or people were like,
well,
you know,
this,
this can't happen here or anywhere else.
So,
you know,
they got to go win over there so they
don't come here
thing.
But it's a weird feeling that people
have years later after the fact that not
only have we not capitalized on the
situation and used it as a,
uh,
as,
as the potential to sort of rectify some
of the problems that we have.
But instead we ruined the way the rest
of the world looks at America.
We destroyed all the goodwill,
all the praise and happiness that people
had for America responding to this
horrible tragedy,
all the love that people had sent to
America from all across the world within
five,
six years,
America to become the Great Satan again.
Half the fucking world.
They squandered a squad they don't
under.
They capitalized on it.
That's the big thing to capitalize on
it.
They get their money off the top,
you know,
and then they let you know,
they sell the weapons,
they get their money.
They're not around when the war start,
when we go back and have to get smart
and hip to that shit and just go,
you know,
we're not gonna you know what we're
gonna do,
we're gonna do what we did after nine
slash 11.
We're going to like do the right thing
and the good thing for each other.
We're not going to do what you fucking,
you know,
we're not going to be tools in your
useless,
obsolete wars where you make the stock
markets go up because poverty increased
amongst workers in the world.
That's not gonna happen anymore.
I think that's slowly happening.
Yeah,
I do too.
So you agree everything's going to be.
I do agree,
but I also agree and my daughter says,
oh mother,
just because you are getting old enough
to die doesn't mean that any tire world
as a die with you.
That's what baby boomers think because
you guys are so fucking narcissistic.
Not only have we run the world and blah,
blah blah,
but you know,
maybe it.
Maybe it's because I'm
getting old,
but a boy.
I'd like to see a big fucking dent and
the bullshit and machine this bullshit
system.
I think we've already had a big dent.
We just haven't realized it yet.
You know what I was going to say is that
in when we look back in history and we
look at the Iraq war and thing,
they find out that a guy who's a ceo of
Halliburton,
somehow or another got to be the vice
president of the United States.
We went into a war under dubious
pretenses that there are some weapons of
mass destruction in some assholes,
shitty fucking country in the middle of
nowhere a million people die when they
look at the profits that were
distributed to Halliburton and all these
different companies that profited from
the rebuilding,
it's going to be so fucking transparent.
When they stop and they step back and
they look at it,
and then I think the other thing is
going to be this Edward Snowden thing.
People just made it possible for the
survivors of the nine slash 11 victims
to sue Saudi Arabia that that just
passed last week.
Did you know that there's a big
admission for people to look at.
People need to read about that.
Well,
the Saudis,
the hostages were.
Excuse me,
the hijackers were Saudis.
Most of them,
right,
but there are.
They're the ones who did it,
I mean,
they're dead if they,
if,
if that's the story.
People say that it was just a regular
move,
a vampire,
you know,
the whole,
uh,
the whole banking empire that runs
through the whole thing that they set it
up,
they did it theater.
Doesn't that seem like that would be a
really fucking difficult thing to
arrange and that would be really hard to
pull off,
pull off getting people to commit
suicide by flying planes into buildings.
Oh,
you mean getting operatives,
getting people to do that,
getting people to commit suicide by
taking a little plane and flying them
right into a building.
It's easy.
If you had like,
you know,
again,
enough whores and drugs and money and
then they sat their family up,
people will do it.
I think it's incredibly difficult to
arrange that plan that I'm saying that
Saudi Arabia had anything to do with it.
What do,
you certainly did?
I think that the idea that the bankers
organized it and set it up in order to
rob people more that the government set
up in order to use it as a pretest,
Iveta invade Iraq.
I think it's much more likely that the
capitalized on a situation and look for
an opening that they had been looking
for in the first place.
They were practicing it for a while.
Always have been,
always have been,
always will be.
You know,
they're always.
They're always,
they're all connected.
We're all connected.
All the people who do that kind of stuff
all around the world,
you know their arms merchants and you
know their operatives well,
there's certainly people that are
connected like that all around the
world.
There's certainly people that profit
from from war all around the world.
I think much more likely though this was
the consequence of our actions overseas.
People say that,
but I'm not sure.
I didn't.
People say it was Silverstein getting
insurance payout out more sense to me.
Tower
seven as well.
Right.
That was the thing that he said.
Pull it.
Yeah.
He told them to pull it.
It's like the.
It's the whole thing,
you know,
it's um,
you have to burn your building down to
get the insurance money
[inaudible] it wasn't getting rented.
Yeah,
no,
that's true.
I mean,
look,
that's,
that is something we've seen on smaller
levels.
You know,
we've seeded on lower levels.
The homeowners like their house on fire.
There was a guy recently who was
indicted for murder because he opened up
his gas line and then set a timer and
for a spark to go off.
Uh,
but he had no idea how much of an
explosion of create and he blew up the
neighbor's house to and killed a couple
people.
I mean,
it's just some crazy asshole that
wanted.
He wanted some money.
Yeah.
Here's how they fix the world.
I don't know.
No,
they have to get rid of insurance
because it's the biggest.
It's just a fucking scam.
Especially life insurance.
Gambling.
You're gonna fucking die.
You don't need to have an insurance
policy saying you're not,
you know,
because you are so already.
It's a fucking scam.
And everything in this country is run by
insurance.
Ha Hack insurance salesman.
Basically a bunch of guys that used to
be in prison and then,
you know,
they couldn't get a real fucking job,
so they started in insurance sales.
So a guy like Larry Silverstein who
would have in the conspiracy model to
have those buildings destroyed,
he would have no incentive to do that
because he couldn't be able to get,
get money from it.
So it stopped things like that from
happening.
Well,
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying people are saying that.
I'm saying these are things I've heard.
Of course.
Well,
if you go on those fucking customer,
they're all,
they all make as much sense to the other
thing.
No,
I don't think that they make as much
sense.
I think that,
uh,
there's a lot of chaos in,
in,
in horrible tragedies.
And a lot of people look for order in
that chaos.
And one of the things they look for is
conspiracy.
I think it's a natural.
I don't think it's any conspiracy that a
bunch of rich guys get together who own
everything on earth,
get together and hang out.
That's not any conspiracy.
And they do.
They all fucking know each other.
They have carlyle group,
so the whole thing,
they know what they're doing,
you know,
and uh,
they make money from the shit they,
they set up like going to the roulette
wheel.
I'm gonna bet.
Read on 22.
Well,
here's another thing that,
uh,
someone said I repeated a wish I could
credit the original person,
but a might actually been awesome.
Were stoned as fuck,
I don't even remember.
But the original quote was that
September 11th when,
when people talk about conspiracy
theories,
that's one of the big ones.
And people always go,
do you believe?
What do you think about September 11th?
I always ask people,
do you believe the September 11th
happened?
And they were like,
what do you mean?
Do you believe that planes were,
were hijacked?
And they flew them into buildings and
they killed a bunch of people.
Do you believe that that happened?
It,
most people say yes.
And I say,
well then you believe in conspiracies
because
they conspired to do that.
They'd have to be a conspiracy.
The only way you get planes to fly into
buildings show it's fake where they show
it to all fake.
That's probably CIA shit right there.
That's probably to diffuse the
architects and engineers for nine slash
11 truth and pink along those lines that
are asking for for answers because even
if they're wrong,
they're still stirring the pot so much
that it makes it hot for anybody who's
in public office.
It makes it difficult.
So this is a natural inclination.
That's the other conspiracy that
everybody talks about.
That's a fascinating one that people
have been wanting more and more lately
to pin on Lee Harvey Oswald as being the
lone gunman.
And I think that's hilarious because
people are moving away from that.
No,
no,
no.
There's a lot of people.
What was that guy that wrote that book?
Cape Vincent Bugliosi,
however you say his last name,
he wrote a book called case closed,
which is fucking retarded.
It's not closed at all.
Like the idea that there's a lot of
people that,
uh,
that were witness to,
that,
that wound up murdered a wound up dying
in very strange ways.
More than a hundred over 10 years and
they said that the odds of those people
all dying like that,
but some fucking astronomical number.
It's fascinating to follow it.
It is.
All these years.
I remember I was in about the fifth
grade when they came in and they said
that we're were Latin school out early
on account of our president has just
been set.
His Dad being shot.
That was freaky.
That's one of those you never forget
where you were moments,
right?
I was so mad because that night I was
having my first slumber party and we're
going to have the scary movies and
there's only like three channels and it
was all about the president in that.
So they preempted all the scary movies.
So cancel my party was.
That sucks because back then do you have
a VCR?
Didn't have anything.
You have to deal with it,
but it was the movie I wanted to see it.
Was that one about the clay to burrata?
Nick tell.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
you'll hit the fuck.
Was that,
uh,
the guy with the spaceship and from came
from outer space?
Is that what it was,
that it wasn't more of worlds?
Was it more of worlds?
It was war of worlds.
I think somebody that claimed to know.
I wanted to say that when I was running
for president so bad on a stage,
how many war of worlds have there been?
Those are the 2005.
One which was full.
People were screaming in the streets and
they thought we really had been invaded.
They say they're going to do another one
like that,
a fake alien invasion movie and I'm.
I'm projected onto the stuff that is in
the chem trails and that people are
going to see a fault and artificial
reality right before their eyes.
Jamie's got it the day the earth stood
still.
That was it.
That was awesome.
I watched that the other day actually.
I just said though,
yes I did.
I see people like
are programmed in America that they
can't hear that they can't hear it.
Do you think that they would actually do
that?
Like if there was something like a war
of worlds type thing?
Again,
remember winning the Orson Welles did
that on the radio and freak the pop
population out.
You could get sued if he did something
like that today,
wouldn't you?
If you had like a fake news story and
people are committing suicide because
they thought the aliens were attacking,
they say they're going to do it to get
people that run to the fema camps.
I've got one place where there's water
and food,
so they'll go,
I have one piece of advice.
Whoever they are,
don't listen to them anymore.
They're.
They're telling you some crazy shit.
It's all day.
That's what they say.
That's a base a say.
He gets to the FEMA camps.
Yeah.
Doesn't make any sense.
I'll tell you what doesn't make any
sense.
You can't get a straight answer anywhere
on the Internet.
It's all fucking bullshit on both sides.
The where's the real news,
but here's the problem with the Fema
camp thing.
Here's the number one problem.
You got to feed this fucking people.
You gotta take care of either going to
kill them,
which costs money because you're gonna
have to get rid of the bodies and shoot
them and all that shit,
and then they're not going to contribute
any money to tax dollars anymore.
That's what I said.
You don't lock up your own tax base and
yet that's what they're doing.
Started locking everybody up for pot.
Really locking up though.
A lot of kids that work a little bit of
that,
but there's also they're profiting off
of putting people in prison.
A lot of them young black men and
they're putting people that are a part
of this disenfranchised system.
Yeah,
and Latino and they're profiting off of
them.
They're just using them to make profit,
but they're not.
They're not taking like the biggest,
baddest tax donators in the world.
They're not doing that.
They're going after people that are in
poverty.
That's why,
because those people oftentimes are
contributing to the system as far as tax
money anyway.
They might buy like sales tax and things
along those lines,
but they're probably not making enough
money declared to pay a significant
amount of income tax.
There's nothing left to be robbed.
Yes.
Well,
there are other also the got a fucking
terrible.
Roll the dice by life threatening.
They start out in massive debt from the
jump because they're born into some
terrible society.
They're born into a horrible
neighborhood.
Terrible parents,
terrible crime filled streets around the
system that exploits the many for the
benefit of the few.
It certainly is.
Yeah,
but that can easily be changed.
It can be changed by some people have
some fucking brains in their head.
They'd go,
Geez,
I don't want to have to live on top of a
mountain behind 18 sets of gates.
Yeah.
Helicopter over the fucking a.
what's it called?
Grand Canyon Grocery still.
What's it called?
Ralph's.
Yeah,
something like that.
It's like I got to have bodyguards in
the helicopter over the roof of Ralph's.
You can't.
You can't divorce.
You can't like take that may steps back
from humanity.
You can't.
They I'll go nuts to do you see the shit
they do because they're so fucking
crazy.
You.
One thing that's consistent in this
conversation is the word day and I think
in a bad way and in a good way,
and I say get the good way is that it's
always a va,
which corporation.
It's a bunch of people acting together
doing terrible things and I think that
where we're wrong as a culture is not
that we don't think of ourselves as
individuals,
but we don't think of giant groups as
as being a bunch of different
individuals together.
You become a part of this corporation
then you become a va.
I know I can get away with shady.
FIne.
No,
you're right with that stupid fuckers.
Maybe real definitive here.
Stupid backward,
lemming,
motherfucking idiots that are in control
of everything.
Um,
but are they just a part of this fucked
up system that we're talkIng about?
Like if you,
if you come along,
like say if you're going to work for
some guy who's a fucking crazy control
freak and you're working in his office
and know they have specific rules to
company rules that you have over the
coffee machine and the way he wants you
to dress,
the way he wants you to talk.
if you're trying to advance inside that
system,
you behave the way that
system is,
that we got to get rid of all
corporations.
They're the enemy.
Everything,
decent government and everything.
But,
um,
you know,
they're bullshit.
They're also where we get laptops
democratic.
There's no democracy and a Fucking
corporation.
It's corporate feudalism.
That's what's forced it oN a,
on all of us.
And you have to do what your boss says.
He might be on coke.
Of course he is on there all fucking
uncle and he might be answering on
godly.
Well,
he'll be on adderall.
some people are not meant for him,
but I mean,
and it's at his whim that you live and
die.
That ain't right.
That's what corporations do.
And,
and these fucking,
uh,
you know,
servants that they put on the supreme
court to make a corporation,
a human.
I think we should take advantage of that
and do just the opposite and get all the
american people together,
not to,
to never vote,
never cast another fucking boat and
incorporate.
And then we'll build the fucking
government for the money they fucking
stole from us in the first god damn
place.
We'll get our money back.
strong words from roseanne barr,
ladies and gentlemen,
strong words or not or not.
You know,
one of the things that I thought was
fascinating that you were talking about,
one of your reasons why you love Hawaii
is because they still have a goddess.
You still have an active goddess.
I think it's a,
it's a fascinating thing in our culture
that somewhere along the line of being a
woman or respecting the idea of a
goddess,
you know,
is completely eliminated from,
from the whole structure of the culture.
It's kinda gone.
There's women,
there's mothers as wives.
Is that the strong feMinine power
structure that you know,
like,
or power position of the goddess doesn't
exist in the feminine.
All these fucked up cultures.
Well,
that's what they get.
I gotta get rid of first because it
makes too much sense to women when they
got to try to fuck with women's minds
that that's what they spend 99 percent
of their lives doing.
That the idiots because they got to get
women to continue to,
um,
you know,
bear bear,
bear kids for them to send off to wars
and molest.
Oh,
what ended thinking?
the things that like the,
the,
the standard of feminine or the,
uh,
the,
the philosophy of feminine though
they're just a natural instinct and
inclination is to take care of things.
Nurturing things,
be loving to thing.
That's a little bit.
That's not exactly.
Everyone says that the yang and the
union of things,
women,
it's the correct thing.
You,
when you See your kids going to chew on
an electric cord,
like they'll do these fucking idiot.
You say,
get the fat down.
That's it to every.
All parents say that,
but that's out of love that you are
doing that.
So that's what feminine is.
And well,
you would also say that there's,
there's a yin and a yang.
The masculine is more aggressive and
more,
and if you look at like a society that's
spiraling out of control,
it'll go one way or the other.
It'll go too far one way or too far the
other way.
And the,
you know,
the amazons or fucking kidnapping man
and cutting their dicks off amazon
women.
Where's that a book?
I'm just making it.
That would be a society like shit,
man.
The women have taken control.
That would be awful.
Of course they do.
They don't want to cut it off.
I mean,
being a women like men who have
erections,
that's the bottom of fucking line.
Of course they do.
That's what you're seeking.
However,
you know that there are so intelligent
systems and it seems that women are the
ones who actually think of them because
they have to like,
in what way?
What intelligence systems?
Oh,
well,
like,
you know,
uh,
a lot of,
you know,
social change comes one.
Women start doing it also,
social change really?
Yeah,
and community social and start
implementing a smarter system that
changes things right away and there's
all kinds of evidence out there that you
can read about like right now in africa,
a whole bunch of new systems,
you know,
and women are the ones who are like
thinking them up because like I said,
a lot of these women,
myself included in the old days,
you had to fix a whole lot of shit with
gestures and a rubber band and a
paperclip.
You had to like organize the fucking
shit load of people around you to do
what needed to be done for the group.
it's like hive mind and we were trained
for that.
So it's like,
you know,
if we're all going to survive in this
family,
this is what I need you to do.
If we need to make our common goal
visible and all work towards it.
Not against it.
And that's what the mother brings to a
family and the father too.
But the mother is the one who's there
every day.
But in general,
I'm speaking in generalities,
but she's there and she implements that
system of sharing.
And commonwealth,
do you know dr chris ryan is.
Have you ever heard of.
Haven't heard of the book sex at dawn
[inaudible].
He's a good friend and we've had them on
the podcast several times and he's a
really,
really brilliant guy and one of the
things that he talked about was that in
hunter gatherer cultures,
the relationship between the man and the
woman was much,
much,
much more equal because the women did a
huge amount of that work.
A hUge amount of the reason why
everybody was surviving and taking care
of their children and feeding themselves
was because of the gathering part.
It wasn't so much the hunting.
The men would be out doing the hunting.
They would be successful occasionally,
but it wasn't all the time.
So they relied on crops.
they relied on the things that they grew
in,
the things that they picked.
And that because of that,
the women had a prominent position of
power and in those cultures.
Yeah,
because we,
we,
we got our,
our thinking is a little more circular,
not always,
but in generalities,
a little more connected,
a little more,
you know,
we're men seems to be um,
a equals b,
it seems this way.
What do you call that?
Hierarchal or something and they're
trained to do that.
I,
I don't doubt that it could be switched
at any point if you're training people,
but after you've been doing something
for a couple thousand years,
it kinda comes into your dna and nine it
gets like it's your default because you,
you've been while bread or program for
that,
you know,
but I don't think that is who we are.
I think were much smarter than what
we're allowed to be.
And I think that,
you know,
if we had ultimate freedom and small
groups of communities of self rule where
it was the goal of each community to be
sustainable and justice and trade with
your neighbor,
I think we'd be a lot better because
that is who we are before we all got
fucked up with this shit.
I think you're right.
and I think that one of the things that
these things represent what you started
talking about,
like an ancient culture that you know,
favored women more or culture over here
that favors men more or get weirdness
like papau new Guinea where they
sexually molest young boys from the time
they're young.
They take them away from their parents
and they,
they make them ingest men,
semen,
they call them semen warriors.
It's crazy.
But what is that?
Well that represents this,
this crazy range that we have of,
of behavior patterns.
So people tend to follow.
And I think that discussion and
communication and things like these,
these conversations are what lead people
to start analyzing the behavior
structure and the conversation makes
people look at the way things are and
compare them to whether it's passive
realizations or civilizations like
Iceland or whatever it is.
And they start thinking about
reorganizing and reengineering the
system because the system is just that.
It's something that people create and it
might be good and,
but people
have accepted because they've been
brainwashed into it.
They've been brainwashed into thinking
that it's our master,
but it's our tool.
And you know,
it take it,
it is a government that makes that
happen.
Just efficient,
you know,
efficient government.
It's like we've never,
we've never really had that here.
You're right.
And it's so corrupt now at this point
that I agree with what you said earlier
before that thing.
Well,
I think it is.
And uh,
I have,
you know,
I have hope in my fellow humans,
not in,
not in any fairy tale way,
but um,
you know,
there's a movement now and starting in,
uh,
in,
in Italy and it's going to go
everywhere.
It's called the five star movement.
And it has a,
you know,
new systems of law,
the international tribunal of common law
of a,
and I'm saying it wrong,
but it's like common commonwealth common
law and uh,
you know,
it's like taking the idea of sovereignty
on,
on behalf of,
you know,
the regular people of this planet,
all the citizens of this planet.
And um,
you know,
judging the people who have caused an
imposed misery for no reason by profit.
And you know,
the people,
they do have that power and it is coming
in.
It is because of the internet and it is
because the shows like this,
because we can talk this way,
you know,
I have faith in my menu or generation,
younger people might.
My kids are your age,
little bit younger,
probably just your age,
but uh,
you know,
y'all are getting smarter and you,
you will,
um,
you know,
you're going to solve a lot of stuff
because you're smart and you have the,
you have the technology and the tools at
your disposal to do so.
I think it's really the people far
younger than me that are,
I think it's the people that are
listening to people like us having these
conversations and these are the first
first exposures.
They've had these ideas and he'll shape
them and change them while they're still
young.
I think the rigid people that get into
their thirties with mortgages and
forties and what have you,
those are the really hard ones to
fucking change.
But you get a hold of some 18 year old
kid is just out of high school and knows
whose parents are retarded.
And you know,
he goes to college and he listens to a
podcast where rosanne breaks down what's
wrong that that plants a seed in his
head or her head and then from there
they go on and they improve the,
the structure from where they can access
it as at the beginning,
at any point it can be,
you know,
even one small change
right out of college not being saddled
down with mortgages and kids and all
this different stuff that makes it
really,
really hard to change.
But be free from the jump and then
engineer your life and in turn affect a
lot.
I think
it's really scary.
Awesome.
Cool.
Is that,
it's far younger than even them because
like I have a lot of.
I don't know if you looked into it,
there's a lot of hope for autistic
people think
because they are very solution driven
and I'm on that spectrum,
you know,
but,
but they're able to conceive of the idea
of actual solutions,
actual problems instead of how am I
going to make money off this problem,
which is like my generation and and
disappearing.
But kids as young as nine years old are
implementing incredible systems on the,
on the internet that actually like,
you know,
uh,
um,
what do you call it for battering,
battering and fuel batteries and fuel
and all kinds of new things.
Sure.
These guys,
these people are unbelievable.
These young,
really young and especially the ones who
have intense focus.
Their focus is so intense that they can
only do one thing.
But when applied,
I mean they're,
these are like some of the greatest
thinkers as per solutions that have ever
existed.
And now this is like the time of magic
as I really like.
Because one time I want to tell you the
story,
but you finished and then.
Oh no,
no,
please do.
Oh,
this was like a thing that really fucked
up my mind.
I was at this party in,
there was all these people,
you know,
from all over the place.
And there was this guy there and he had
done all the satellite work for ted
turner at the time,
you know,
when they started cable news and
everything.
And he,
he was telling me what his opinion of
the impact of technology and,
and freedom of information for people to
be able to.
And,
and here's what he said,
because I think of it everyday.
So for the first time in history,
human history information reaches the
people without any state,
without any church stopping it.
He said this,
this is going to give birth to something
that the people in the who look at the
renaissance as like a great time,
that's not,
it's going to be a million times.
But he said this is going to be the time
of great freedom.
And he said in the greatest thing about
it is that,
you know,
the ills of the world will begin to
disappear because people will be smart
enough when we won't want to walk over
dead bodies anymore because they'll
realize that what they do,
it is who they are and anyone into this
whole thing.
And I think I think of it every day.
And uh,
and I,
I look for evidence that it's true and I
find it everywhere,
all over the internet.
Smart people,
they know the right thing to do.
They know that this at the time were
they know us just deciding that we're
going to do the right thing for the
right reason at the right time.
It's never been done and now it's
possible in this the first time that
it's really been possible for people to
like really get together and um,
demand and bring change and a whole,
a whole new world,
a whole new world.
And we can do it all with everything
that already exists.
We don't have to have any wars and we
don't have to reinvent the wheel either.
It all exists.
What we need is the right intelligence,
intelligence
and philosophy at the top,
driving it.
And that exists to.
You're so much more positive than you
were two hours ago.
Well,
here's why I'm positive because he is as
positive vr.
You know about zen and stuff for as
much,
you got to stay in balance.
The reason that you can be that positive
as you are aware of how negative it is,
you need what?
You got to have both.
You've got to have both because you have
to see how fucking stupid shit is.
I often think that that's one of the
things that motivates good things,
is it seeing eviL in the world and it's
almost like it has to exist in order to
motivate good because we're so.
We're so far from perfect.
We're so far from finished.
you know,
if we used to be monkeys and now we're
at this,
we're not done.
It's not.
We're not stopping right here.
Whatever we're going to be a million
years from now is going to be very
difficult to do.
It's going to be very difficult to
compare to what we are today.
We're gonna.
We're going gonna change.
We're gonna evolve.
We have to this point,
we're going to continue to do so.
Whether we evolve or they don't like the
word evolve,
they elect to use the word have only
evolved with genetics,
advanced,
culturally advanced,
biologically advancing our understanding
of each other and advance even further
in our ability to spread information.
We're not done.
So the evil almost motivates that work.
It almost motivates that positive work
to get things done.
yeah,
because like the evil thing,
after it's done killing everything good.
It like cancer,
the cancer cell,
and this is genetics.
It doesn't stop killing until the host
is dead [inaudible] and then it,
you know,
it becomes the host and updates itself.
It eats its own tail
well and even on a different way of
looking at it,
what we're talking about earlier about
New York,
about people experiencing that horrible
evil of this attack and thousands of
people dead and then millions of people
being friendly to each other.
There's this burst in the other
direction
that was like,
to me that was like,
this is the messiah moment that first of
all that wall street appreciated the
work that people who do the actual work
that makes things go.
Like when they go to the wall and flip
that switch.
The people that make the electricity
come,
you know the people that raise their
kids and put the food on their tables
and grow it.
Those people that do the actual work
that they were being very appreciative
and I thought this is a mind blowing
fucking revolutionary moment in the
United States.
History were bullshit is not walking and
bullshit is not talking,
but reality and reality is being honored
and people are so fucking happy.
Matt,
they were all smiling at each other.
They were tripping over themselves to
give somebody a hand.
It was intense and I never will forget
it neither.
I won't forget it either.
I remember that feeling.
It was a very,
very,
very strange time and it didn't last,
but it let me know that that that time
is possible,
that things like that can take place
where people do wake up and kind of
realize and think.
One of the big things
was that it happened here.
We've been so lucky when you consider
how much war the United States has been
involved in and how little of it has
been on the United States soil outside
of pearl harbor,
which is barely on United States soil.
It's like it's in the middle of the
ocean.
It's Hawaii,
Hawaii.
I think it should be its own nation.
I just do.
I think it is a totally unique thing.
I think it should have its own,
you know,
its own rules,
its own government.
I think they need the United States
money for certain things because of
that,
but fuck that.
It's moved to where it's like the leader
of the United States because it's the
only place where either they've outlawed
gmos and China just said,
we're not going to buy any gmo,
so there you go.
There's a whole market there that Hawaii
is a very set up to be able to fulfill.
It's a paradise nation.
It's a paradise in the middle of the
ocean.
The idea that it's a part of the United
States,
it's crazy,
but they've been attacked.
Pearl harbor thing was the only time,
so we didn't have a point of reference,
so we're involved in all this shit
that's going on over the globe where we
are involved in Iraq.
We are involved in Afghanistan,
but you and I and everybody that's here
in America,
we don't feel that.
We don't.
Unless you have friends or loved ones
that are over there,
you don't feel it.
I don't know.
I think people have send their children
over there.
Those people feel like there's a bunch
of people who,
who felt it and what's really sickening
to me is that those people who sent
their kids over there to fight for what,
you know,
an idea that they agreed with and that
everybody agrees with,
that's what they were sold.
And that's what they did.
And then they come home to find that
their pr,
their parents,
that class of people who've lost their
homes.
I mean,
when people put that one together,
I always hope,
you know,
of course I want,
uh,
the,
the american people deserve healthcare.
And if they had given us healthcare,
they wouldn't had any war in Iraq.
I want somebody to put that together
too.
That was all bankster bullshit to avoid
paying for medicare for all because they
needed to get away from what they call a
socialist model.
So they start breaking it down and it
was all around healthcare and it would
have been a whole fuck of a lot cheaper
to just give people healthcare.
But it wasn't,
it.
It paid off those private contractors
who go over to other countries and not
only do they blow everything up,
but then they rebuild it.
Then they blow it up again and then they
rebuild it.
They're getting paid four times of doing
that because it's just a fucking scam.
When you say it's about healthcare,
meaning that they shifted where the
money would go,
that it would have to go to war.
so there wouldn't be money for health
care.
It was up there because they didn't want
any socialist solution.
I just say socialist solution,
they call it,
you know,
they,
they've got people thinking that
socialism means you're behind barbed
wire with a gun to your head or that
you're weak and lazy and you don't want
to do any work.
But that's how you fucking a middle
class.
You take
the shit from the top and move it to the
middle.
So they just bullshitted everybody and
you know,
they,
they use the way they always use.
They use a lot of racism and they use an
absolute classes,
um,
to divide people against each other and
do their fundraising shit or you know,
they and,
and all the laws that they changed since
reagan were deregulation laws and it was
so that there were,
they deregulated the insurance company,
so like bosses can take peasant
insurance out on their employees and so
if they die,
they get a kickback,
judges get a kickback,
you know,
they took public money and put it in
private pockets and they did it all
through their lobbyists who sit in
congress and have nothing to do with
serving the needs of the people who sent
them there.
Now that is some bullshit.
That's fucking hilarious.
What it is.
Sometimes you can write comedy like
that.
Well,
it's,
I don't think it's hilarious.
I think it's disgusting,
but I agree with you that it's
hilarious.
I'll fucking transparent it is.
And I think that you breaking it down
like that is going to let people sort of
look at it from that point of view.
They got everybody fired by boat flagged
by both bible facts because you made me
forget to verado nickname used to
fucking catch phrases of bullshit
against it doesn't mean shit.
You're not going to get shit for it.
Right?
Your kid ain't going to get nowhere.
He's not getting any school.
But like I have made my family was like,
well,
we need to be able to.
This was like it in Hawaii to where this
old lady gets up there.
It made me so fucking mad.
She goes,
I'm 82 years old and I'm a I a,
I may a gmo farmer.
And um,
you know,
uh,
I made it to.
And if I didn't have my gmo crops,
I wouldn't be able to send my grandkids,
my children to college.
And they get up there,
their testimony.
I want to go to college.
No,
but I go up there and go,
I don't care how old you are,
you don't have the right to give my
grandkids asthma.
Hello?
But they don't,
they don't commit to anything because
there are fucking on dope for one thing.
They're on all that fucking.
They're depressed as fuck.
America takes two thirds of the world's
antidepressants and then they got to
antidepressant booster on top of every
year.
If it doesn't make you forget reality
quick enough and you know,
they're just drowning in bullshit,
but they,
they,
they want bullshit more than they want
anything else.
It's like a fucking incredible
addiction.
Give us our bullshit.
Give us our fucking bullshit.
But it's all fucking bullshit.
It's all fucking bullshit because it's.
Truth is scary
because it's simple and they can't stand
simple because they don't feel smart and
less.
It's all convoluted labyrinths of
bullshit.
The,
the,
the simple truth is fucking overwhelming
to them because they're fucking liars.
So they're like,
hi,
how am I going to stand here?
Have something to come
out of my mouth.
How am I going to do that?
Um,
I won't be getting paid for that.
I mean,
the people themselves that are addicted
to the bullshit,
like,
what?
What is,
what's feasible?
And that's why I say I don't use it.
They,
they have convoluted hope until people,
oh,
you,
there's hope that you're gonna make it.
There's hope you're going to climb out
of that hole.
There's hope,
there's a payoff,
there's hope you're going to win in the
casino.
There isn't any fucking hope.
All there is is just,
you know,
united with other people helping each
other to get rid of fucking criminals
that are robbing us.
That's certainly the best hope.
So I hope that people will fucking wake
the fuck up.
That's where I hope.
I think they are.
I think.
I think that helped.
That'll become an internet meme.
What you just said.
Someone will take that and turn it into
a clip.
It'll be a video and people say roseanne
barr brick shit down.
Going to say I liked doing it for people
because you know,
they,
you know,
because I can and I like to just go and
I'll read all the shit for you and I'll
tell you what it means to.
Because I feel like,
hey,
you know,
uh,
that's the service I can provide.
Maybe I'm full of shit on some topics.
Look it up for yourself and then come
back and tell me if I am or not.
I'll listen.
But I mean,
somebody's got to put this complete
system of obsolete bullshit.
They start laughing at to scorn and
fucking replace it with something that
fucking makes sense.
I agree.
I just don't know how it's going to
happen.
I wonder what's going to be the trigger.
I hope it's not something catastrophic.
Some some sort of big event that has to
take place in order for them to rebuild
the whole thing and try to do it in some
sort of ethical and moral way.
But I to do is write down the debt.
Like fdr did move the zero.
It's easy.
It's a fucking.
It's a pen on paper.
That's all they have to do.
If they want,
you know,
things to get better in a fucking hurry.
They can write down the debt of the
american people.
They can have a debt jubilee.
They can forgive the debt.
student loan debt.
They can do that or if they want to,
it's totally possible.
Obama could like say,
you know what?
I'm kicking the federal.
Reserve the fuck out of here.
As a matter of fact,
I've been a nationalize it and I'm going
to nationalize monsanto too while I'm at
it because I have that kind of power
under the theater.
You going to do what you gotta do.
Well,
isn't that what happened to kennedy?
I think so,
but you got end lincoln and you gotta do
what you gotta do and those guys are
frigging,
you know,
they did what they had to do and they,
you're going to get that fucking
clothes.
You know,
it's not like you're going to top that.
It's not like you're going to be,
you know,
after you know,
nationalizing the federal reserve and
monsanto.
You're never going to top that.
Did you think that getting a second
fucking sitcom number one thing,
you only get that once he's there with
the chance he could do it.
He could do something.
Did you think that it was going to be
different when he got into office now?
I hate.
I don't like him.
I knew,
I knew he was.
I ran against him.
I came in fifth.
I spent $0.
I spent,
I raised no money and spent no money.
I came in fifTh.
Wow.
But uh,
yeah,
I ran against him because I knew he was
a lobbyist.
Like they all are.
There was no real leaders.
I mean,
I think he's a smart lobbyists and I
don't think he has any chance to,
to do what he does because he's in that
system,
that system of,
of banksters who runs it
against him in 2008.
Is that what it was?
TwElve.
Twelve.
Well,
when he was coming out in 2008,
did you have any belief in him?
No,
I never have any belief in any
republican nor democrat.
I know they're just fucking lobbyists.
You know,
they're not real.
Even politicians,
you know,
they're just liars.
So basically it's fucking liars.
Politicians make bridges between
communities and people for,
for,
you know,
money to come into that community.
These guys don't fucking do any of that.
They just take people's money and put it
in their friends pocket.
Like they know everything they do,
that they're not a,
nothing they do is in the public
interest or,
or for american citizens.
I hope your optimism in people figuring
it out is founded.
Well,
I pray that they will because I want to
use that word because as long as there's
an old crabby,
whatever,
I am,
women like me,
you know,
that are there,
that are able to come on anywheres and
say,
I'm praying that people will wake up and
rejoin the human race.
I think that's a pretty free society
that you're living in
free as you can get in today's climate
and and,
But you know,
they're working very hard to restrict
those freedoms and that's what's scary
about the nsa holding things on over
people,
digging into your email,
being able to have things that they can
pull on you.
Like you were saying before that they're
all a bunch of fucking people that have
done shady shit and they know that they
have secrets out there and they want to
have your secrets as well and they want
to hold them over your head and keep you
from trying to change the system.
So when a person like you comes along,
that doesn't give a fuck,
that's,
that's when the truth gets hurt.
When a person that doesn't have anything
to lose,
you have comic.
You got to tell you you can't get up
here and then you can't fucking
bullshit.
You can'T live if you're just
bullshitting people,
you know,
you,
you want to hit them right fucking
between the eyes and for me and like my
idol,
dick gregory and other ones.
It's like I'm not even fucking make it
funny.
I'm just going to say it to you because
it's like you have people.
We have the power,
right?
We,
we have the power,
we have all the power that it takes to,
uh,
ensure that a better system is
implemented with the least amount of
cruelty possible.
That's a great way you have it.
I believe we do.
Dick gregory was the guy for a lot of
folks.
Don't know who put the zapruder film on
television and made people.
Yeah,
he was the guy in 1970.
Actually.
It was a long after a 70.
Something might not be me.
It might have been 71.
It was right after,
um,
uh,
it was on the geraldo rivera show
actually.
They showed the zapruder film live on
television,
and back then geraldo was this
antigovernment guy who's just like
really controversial character.
Look,
we can waTch it right here.
What year was it,
jamie?
Back that up real quick.
Just put on the back it up to the
beginning.
Okay.
Straight out that if you are at all
sensitive,
uh,
if your idol queasy then don't watch
this film.
Just putting on the late night.
They're going to show this film.
This is geraldo rivera back when he was
super slick with a beautiful mustache
and lovely hair.
And it was called good night America.
And it was geraldo show.
He was the most radical did he was a
young man and he was a wild fuck.
He was very different than he is now.
His little fox news.
Bruter film.
Dick gregory got ahold of this video.
Time magazine owned it from 1963 on
zapruder.
Submitted it to them in 1963.
They bought it and then no one released
it until 1970.
What was it?
Seventy what?
Seventy five.
So think about that.
You're talking about eight years after
the murder was the first time it gets on
tv,
and here it is.
This is the first time people see
kennedy's head explode on television and
go back into the left.
They'd never seen that before and
that all of the shots were fired from
behind by lee harvey oswald alone,
assassin firing at the president,
and as you could see clearly the head is
thrown violently backwards.
Can completely.
That's a dIck.
Gregory.
Dick gregory.
Put that on television.
So your hero was responsible for
something you didn't even know about.
That was one of the big moments where
people in the United States started
going,
what?
The kennedy assassination was the one
for me when I was.
I was living in New York and my friend
john,
he had this buddy who was over the house
who had this book that was a fucking
wave it around talking all this crazy
shit about this book.
It was called best evidence by this guy
david lifton.
David liftin was an accountant start
going over the warren commission reports
and he was one of the only guys that was
anal enough to go through all fucking
who knows how many hundreds and hundreds
of pages and find all these
inconsistencies and contradictions and
all this hypocrisy and craziness and all
incorrect shit,
and he.
He made like a long list of what it was
and explained and then went on this
lifelong quest to get to the bottom of
what happened during the kennedy
assassination and the result was this
book called best evidence that is one of
the most analytical books ever and
analytical about the crime in a way that
was not emotional.
IT wasn't theatrical,
wasn't trying to lead you in one
direction or the other.
It was just simply stating the facts
like the reason why the single bullet
theory was concocted in the first place.
The single bullet itself appearing on
connelly's gurney magically at the
hospital and being responsible for going
through to people's bodies and leaving
more in residue of the bullets and
connally's body.
Then was missing from the actual bullet
itself.
So much horseshit involved in the
concoction of the single bullet theory
in the first place because they only did
it because they had a.
They had a makeup for a guy getting hit
with a ricochet and the underpass.
A guy went to the hospital and he got
hit and he was doing interviews and
talking about it.
He got hit with a bullet that hit the
curb stone and the ricochet hit him in
the head so he.
This guy had to be treated so they had
to account for that bullet and one of
the ways the accounted for that bullet,
it was all these different wounds on two
different people.
They attributed in the one bullet.
Instead of saying,
hey man,
maybe they're getting shot from all over
the place.
We were getting shot from the front and
shot from the back.
They tied it all together.
The first bullet hole and kennedy's
neck.
They turned thAt into a trake wound.
It's a different wound in the protest.
The Maryland hospital as it is,
and the dallas hospital.
The way it was described in the dallas
hospital was an entry wound.
The way it was described in bethesda,
Maryland,
by the time they got ahold of the body
and fluid across the country,
they turned it into a tracheotomy.
You don't do a tracheotomy and a guy who
doesn't have a head,
the guy's dead,
never heard any of this.
They had to make something.
They had to account for the fact that he
had a hole in his neck,
so they turned it into a trake wound.
You've got shot from a bunch of
different angles.
There's probably several people shooting
at them.
One of them might've been lee harvey
oswald.
It's not an either or.
You know,
people say lee harvey oswald acted
alone.
I don't know.
He might've acted that either or thing.
That's that binary mind control thing.
so you'd go back and forth like you're
getting all bipolar,
you know,
going back and forth,
but you don't see the real truths.
Right?
Right there in your face.
Here's the,
here's some real facts of it.
Not that those aren't real facts,
but that Gerald Ford was the head of the
warren commission that you know,
came out with a,
a certain report and then became the
analects and president of the United
States for a lot
the creep,
arlen specter,
he was on the warrant commission.
THe warren commission was filled with
criminals and crazy people,
mad men that were designed to
disseminate propaganda and dress it up
as the truth.
Whoever killed kennedy,
whether it was lee harvey oswald
delivered the shot or the idea that what
we're getting is the truth,
the whole truth and nothing,
but that's the most hilarious thing
ever.
Why would they ever do that?
I don't know,
but I agree with you,
but did you see obama shaking raul
castro's hand at mandela's funeral
though?
No.
Did you hear about that?
No,
but did you see the guy who was doing
the fucking translation,
the sign language at mandela's funeral?
Just making shit up.
TO me,
that shows where there's a problem with
conspiracy theory that most of the time
it's in competence.
It's human and competence more than
anything else.
And when you got a guy that's just
making up sign language,
shit standing three feet away from the
president who,
oh,
by the way,
when you go back in his past,
turns out that he was arrested for
murder and he might've been also
responsible for rape.
So it's like all these crazy accusations
about this guy,
he's a violence,
gets a frantic.
He'd already been arrested at one other
time for doing that.
Very same thing.
He got in trouble rather for doing that
very same thing.
He did it before.
I don't know how he got there.
I don't know who hired him,
but he had done that before we had gone
up and pretended to be a sign language
guy.
He's like,
maybe they're given all,
maybe they're telling obama something.
Because remember when you went to south
America and his guys got busted for the
prostitutes.
Well that was actually secret service
people.
But I mean,
well maybe some of the people that get
next to them,
they're not really being vetted very
well.
I certainly think so.
I think it's incompetence.
Like,
like I was saying,
I think there's more than competence in
government than we would ever imagine
and when you see that,
because you can tell that the smart
guide,
the wizards there,
dumb,
well they're smart in some ways,
but I think in order to fuck people
over,
you have to be a liar in order to be a
lawyer.
You got a lot of yourself.
I don't think there's any people,
any people that are dishonest,
that are honest with themselves because
if they're honest with themselves,
they would recognize the terrible
feeling that comes along with leaving,
leaving a legacy of of sadness and
destruction behind you.
leaving a legacy of people upset about
your,
your personal actions.
That's not a Way to be in harmony with
life.
That's not a way to be happy and that's
why people,
but it is for those people.
Like you said earlier,
that are like,
I just want to get over.
That is a joy for them.
I don't think so.
In that way,
I think those people are either die that
way.
I just ride that bitch right into the
beach.
I got my fuck you.
That's all there is,
I think.
I think even those people are not
optimally happy and they they probably
in some way in the back of the head
realized that maybe they drank it away,
maybe they pill it away,
but the way to be happy is to make
people around you feel happy and that's
not the way to do it.
Just by fucking people over and when you
have a million dollars or a billion
dollars and you got so much money in the
bank that you can't even spend it all.
You're not going to notice the
victories.
What you're doing is just continuing to
play the game.
Damn,
that's really true.
When you became super wealthy,
do you mean you went from being this
person who struggled with and you know,
we're,
we're really fucking in in poverty and
then all of a sudden,
boom,
insane,
incredible wealth.
Once the dust settles you still,
roseanne is still rosanna.
You got to deal with new bullshit,
but you're still,
you.
I don't know if I'm still me.
You don't know if he's still doing it.
Destroyed my nervous system.
I know that.
I love to charge a harrison said that
one time,
but they said the beetle thing and he's
like,
well,
the cost was our nervous system because
of the fame.
The pressure.
Yeah.
It's a lot of pressure.
It's a lot of fame and you know,
I couldn't handle it.
I didn't know if I can even know what
the fuck it was.
And um,
it just seemed like another bullshit
thing.
How old were you when you,
when you hit,
when it really got crazy.
So that's the same thing
saying I did.
I was like,
uh,
you know.
Yeah,
I did go all the way.
fucking nuts.
First thing I did,
I started like a given.
I started giving away the fucking money
because I have like basic beliefs.
Of course they were all sold out and
compromise now I was like,
okay,
you know,
you gotta you do this,
set this up.
But I set up all of these crazy fucking
nonprofit organizations.
I used my money to like,
you know,
uh,
try,
try to do what I,
what I really thought I could,
you know,
blows against the empire shit.
And that was so fun because it's lIke
being a pirate or something,
but yeah,
of course there's a certain time where
it's like,
you know what,
I'm getting a face lift.
And then it was like,
then I got all gm mode like that.
I get,
I got fucking gem mode.
It was exciting and especially because
the pills I gave you,
they give you these fucking awesome
painkillers and shit.
So I just kept having more and more
surgery and you know,
there,
there was a lot of uh,
psychotropic drugs and like I used
fucking three or four.
I about 15 nervous breakdowns.
Luckily no one noticed.
Don't worry my fucking family around me
noticing any difference.
Wow.
But you categorize that miss nervous
breakdowns?
Yeah,
they were a shitload of them.
It's a lot of pressure.
A lot.
It's,
it's not fun.
I mean,
I,
I admire people who are handling it
well,
but why don't you get up to that certain
level.
I mean,
you know,
I'm just saying a lot of people,
they don't survive that level.
And I would see that,
you know,
that
like when you see a miley cyrus going
crazy or a justin bieber going crazy and
everybody has their own criticisms of
them,
you have a particular way of looking at
it.
We like god,
you know,
you don't know what the fuck they're
dealing with.
No one knows.
No one undersTands.
You understand in a way that most
people,
yeah,
they,
they can't trust anybody.
Everyone's crazy and their life is
crazy.
The reality is crazy.
Well,
you know,
they're just around so many vultures in
and a crepe zoids um,
you know,
they don't know what the way,
I don't know if they're coming or going,
plus the amount of fucking,
just the impact of all those people
staring at you all the time.
And everywhere you go,
you goT,
especially now the paparazzi and their
face everywhere.
Like justin bieber can take a shit
without someone having a camera in the
toilet.
And that's just the way it is with that
life.
And most people can't handle that.
That's like a stocking,
like the media they want to stock yet
because they want,
they want to destroy you on camera,
cause that'd be some good ratings.
Well they also feel like they're allowed
to.
They're allowed to just shove cameras in
your face because you're the famous
person.
Yeah.
I wasn't first star that,
uh,
you know,
I mean I had to pay a large amount of
money in settlement,
but I did make the mistake of hiring
some fucking guns to beat the fuck out
of some paparazzi and how much you have
to pay for that.
Oh,
I hAd to pay them all.
A few thousand.
That's worth it.
All the pop razzies kind of cash you
got.
That's worth.
While.
This was way back when,
way back when,
the good old days when I had to pay some
money.
I was like,
yeah,
these fucking people just fucking.
They're jumping on my.
I mean,
you,
you don't know what it's like when you
were like panicked because you know,
you're trying to leave a crowd and
you're in your car and they're fucking
jumping on your car and they're being
encouraged to jump on your car and shit.
It's like,
you know,
and uh,
some farm boys knocked on my window and
I roll it down and then they're like,
do you want us to beat the fuck out of
them were from fucking Iowa?
Yes,
I do,
sir.
They got that hay bale and strength and
they just moved them out of the way so I
could leave,
but I was a sitting duck,
you know,
that kind of shit was weird.
how often are you in California?
You know,
I,
I come here every now and then.
Will you,
will you come back?
We do this again?
Yeah,
it was fun.
I enjoyed it very much.
I enjoyed being with you.
It was a,
and I said,
for me as a,
as a standup comedian is a honor because
I really do.
I'm a very emotional by my nuts.
No,
you're not.
You're awesome.
But you,
you're,
you're one of the greatS in my opinion.
Oh,
you're very sweet.
I do appreciate that.
You know,
there's a lot of great ones right now.
Is a good time for Comedy.
Good time for comedy.
Thank you very much for all your stuff.
Fucking awesome.
I really appreciate it.
And thanks to you guys.
We'll be back tomorrow,
my mess or whatever.
Yeah,
you can if you want.
If you don't,
I'm not.
I love you.
That's a buck.
You as a buck angel.
What's that?
My son's name is buck.
That used to be a girl and now it's a
guy buck angel.
I know him.
He's awesome.
He's a good dude.
He came in,
he did the podcast.
Take that shirt.
all right.
We love you.
Everybody tuning in,
we'd love you to a thanks to our podcast
sponsor.
Thanks to tim,
go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible] dot
com.
Save yourself some money and we'll see
you tomorrow.
Big kiss.
Wow.